Aber sie sind alle im Mittelfest, also kann ich einfach nur...
Ich klingle auf dem Telefon, überall im Mittelfest.
Ja, ich kann nicht in Trommel sein, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Weil ich 66 Satelliten habe, die sich über den Weltkrieg kreischen und so lange ich den Himmel sehe, kann ich diesen Föhn überall auf der Erde benutzen. Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die hier lange wieder ausgehalten haben, um auf eine neue Sendung zu warten. Und ja, ihr werdet jetzt mal wieder beschickt. Und zwar geht es heute sehr in die Technik rein, vielleicht auch ein bisschen in die Gesellschaft, weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau. Und heute sprechen wir über Satelliten, genauer über Satelliten-Netzwerke, Satelliten-Netzwerke mit dem primären Zweck, darüber zu telefonieren und vielleicht auch die eine oder andere Nachricht abzusenden. Und wer weiß, vielleicht in Zukunft auch nochmal richtig viel Internet darüber zu bekommen. Und dazu begrüße ich hier Nibla. Hallo Nibla.
Hallo.
Du warst ja schon mal hier. Wir haben uns schon mal ausführlich über Voice-over-IP unterhalten. Ist eigentlich schon ein bisschen her.
Eine ganze Weile, ja.
Schon eine ganze Weile. Oh man, ja. Ich stelle auch mal wieder fest, ich mache dieses Programm schon so lange. Das war 2007, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Und das ist...
Wo der CRE noch ein bisschen kürzer war.
Wo der CRE noch ein bisschen kürzer war. Und tja, das heißt, das ist schon fast zehn Jahre her. Meine Fresse. Genau, aber so kurz wird es heute wahrscheinlich nicht werden, wenn ich mir das Thema so anschaue. Wir sind auch beide super bei Stimme heute. Mal gucken, wie das so läuft. Da muss man eigentlich noch mal ein bisschen kurz erzählen, was dich eigentlich so in diese Themenwelt treibt. Also ich meine, so mit Telefonen und so und den Netzen hast du es ja schon immer gehabt.
Ja, und auch Weltraum zu einem gewissen Teil mal ein interessantes Thema gewesen. Ich erinnere mich dunkel dran, ja, also schon immer die Faszination dafür da gewesen, aber so eine der Erinnerungen, die mir bis heute noch tief im, das war, da war ich mit meinen Eltern im Urlaub. Ich weiß nicht, wie alt war ich da. Da hatte ich ein Siemens S25.
Also, ein normales, modile Telefon, ja.
Ja, mit einem Infrarot-Port und weswegen ich mich spezifisch an das Modell erinnere, ich hatte mir da noch am Bodensee Karten runtergeladen von Heavens Above. Das ist eine Seite, die einem so Skycharts, also Heavens Karten zur Verfügung steht, auf denen eingezeichnet ist, zu welcher Zeit man wann und wo Satelliten sehen kann. Und da geht es jetzt nicht um Satelliten, die irgendwo fest im Ort stehen, sondern um relativ niedrig fliegende Satelliten. In dem Fall war das Objekt der Faszination Iridium, was ein Satelliten-Mobilfunknetz ist, was sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass die Satelliten Antennen haben, die unglaublich gut das Sonnenlicht reflektieren. Das sieht man dann immer im Morgengrauen oder nach Sonnenuntergang, wo man weiß, wo man hingucken muss. Guckt man rauf und sieht dann so einen Punkt immer heller werden, bis er der hellste Punkt am Nachthimmel ist und dann wieder langsam dunkler wird und so seine Bahn rüber zieht. Das fand ich unglaublich faszinierend.
Der sogenannte Iridium-Flair.
Der Iridium-Flair, genau. Fand ich unglaublich faszinierend. Und der Gedanke mit dem Ding, was man da oben sieht, diesen hellen Punkt telefonieren zu können und dass diese Dinge, dass es da nicht nur einen gibt, sondern da ganz viele von, die untereinander dann kommunizieren und das Gespräch weiter, das fand ich und finde ich auch bis heute einfach faszinierend. Hab dann Informations- und Kommunikationstechnik studiert, aber festgestellt, dass man sich dann da irgendwann spezialisieren muss. Und nach dem Vordiplom waren wir das dann so blöd und hab irgendwie angefangen, mit der IT-Security sichere Rechenzentren bauen und so weiter. Aber das Thema Satellitenkommunikation immer so hobbymäßig. Mit einem Auge verfolgt.
Also du kannst kein abgebrochenes Informatikstudium vorweisen, aber immerhin ein abgebrochenes Informationstechnikstudium.
Ja, das war so ein Querschnittsstudiengang. Das war noch ein bisschen schwierig, weil das ein Diplom-Studiengang war. Den gab es nur an der Uni Erlangen. Das war ein Querschnitt aus Nachrichtentechnik, Informatik.
Okay, das zählt dann auch schon, ein abgebrochenes Informatikstudium. Da wird die Qualifikation für diese Sendung ja geklärt. Gibt ja auch, wer das mal ausprobieren will, ich hab's auch mal gemacht, gibt ja nette Apps für unsere heutigen Smartphones, wo man sich dann mal schön immer wieder davon in Kenntnis setzen lassen kann, wenn so ein Iridium-Flair auftaucht. Das ist gar nicht so selten.
Nee, hatte ich letzten Sommer mit einem Freund im Park gelegen. Es ist die Uhrzeit, lasst uns doch mal gucken, da müsste es doch eine App für geben. Haben wir tatsächlich auch gefunden. Und in dem Moment, wo man sich diese App mit den ganzen Satellitendaten, wo man da mal reinschaut, fällt einem auf, wie viele das sind. Wir lagen da so eine halbe Stunde und haben mindestens vier oder fünf Satelliten sehen können. Also teilweise war es Weltraumschrott, ein Iridium-Satellit war dabei.
Die ISS hat auch immer wieder ihre Visible Passes, die ist ja noch am hellsten, weil wenn die dann erst mal ihre Sonnenkollektoren in den Sonnenschein einstellt, so dass man es sehen kann, dann kommt natürlich enorm viel Licht runter. Also mit allen Worten, durch den Blick nach oben in den Himmel ist ja klar geworden, dass da eine ganze Menge rumfliegt, aber unser Mobilfunk-Freund war es ja schon immer. Und das heißt, dann hast du dich mit Satellitentelefonie beschäftigt?
Ja, mit den wenigen Quellen, die es dann damals gab. Auch heute ist das noch ein Thema, wo man eben relativ wenig detailliert so im Internet findet, weil es einfach so ein Nischending ist. Also du findest jetzt keine ausführliche Systemdescription. Das ist unser Protokoll, wie das bei GSM der Fall ist, was ja auch unterdokumentiert, aber da gibt es wesentlich mehr dazu. Bei Satellitenkommunikationen ist das ein bisschen schwieriger.
Genau, deswegen wollen wir das heute mal so ein bisschen aufdröseln, was man eigentlich dazu wissen kann und wissen sollte. Wie weit muss man denn zurückblättern in der Geschichte, bis man da überhaupt fündig wird? Also was war denn überhaupt der Anlass dafür, dass Satelliten zum Telefonieren hochgeschickt werden?
Da könnte man jetzt sagen, dass es Satelliten gab. Weil in dem Moment, wo eine Technologie wie Satelliten verfügbar sind, denkt man sich natürlich, okay, wofür können wir dieses praktische Ding verwenden? Es hat dann trotzdem ein bisschen die 70er gedauert, bis der Interessenträger der IMO, die International Maritime Organization, gesagt hat, hey, Satelliten werden super praktisch, dann könnten wir mit unseren Schiffen mal direkter sprechen. Man müsste nicht über Kurzwelle die anfunkten, sondern dann könnte ja vielleicht sogar jedes Schiff ein eigenes Telefon bekommen. Dann könnte man diese Schiffe anrufen. Das wäre total praktisch mit diesen modernen Satelliten. Dann geht das ja. Das war in den 70ern.
In den 70ern. Also quasi die Schiffe haben es ausgelöst.
Ja, da war zumindest der Bedarf am größten da.
Ja, ist ja auch klar. Man hat keinen Kontakt zu den Schiffen. Die sind dann irgendwo so auf dem Atlantik und Kurzwelle, gut, hat funktioniert, geht halt irgendwie rum über den Planeten, aber dann muss da die ganze Zeit einer sitzen.
Ja, die haben auch den Bedarf, Informationen hinzubekommen, wie zum Beispiel Wetterkarten und so weiter. Das ist auch über Kurzwelle eher mühsam.
Und was wurde dann getan?
Na ja, erst mal eine Kommission.
Also jetzt bei wem? Also die Maritime Organization dürft ihr jetzt nicht so die Kenntnisse haben?
Ja, die haben sich trotzdem gedacht, wir brauchen sowas und das ist ja auch keine UN-Organisation.
Genau, das ist eine UN-Organisation. Also wir reden jetzt hier nicht von so einem privaten Verbund, sondern das ist sozusagen die internationale Seeschifffahrtsorganisation, wie das dann so schön heißt auf Deutsch. Also die IMO hat sich dann sozusagen an die Unternehmen gewendet und gesagt, macht doch mal was. Wär doch schön, wenn man mit den Schiffen telefonieren könnte. Und was wurde dann daraus gebaut?
Das American Institute of Merchant Shipping ist da vorgeprescht und hat, ich glaube, in Zusammenarbeit mit der US Navy, die Firma Huge Aircraft beauftragt, Satelliten zu bauen. Das waren die ersten Marisat-Satelliten. Drei Stück, weil man braucht drei Satelliten im stationären Orbit, um die Erde, wie war es in so ein Drittel, Scheiben komplett abzudecken. Weil es ging ja darum, wirklich die Weltmeere nahrtlos mit Satelliten zu versorgen.
Drei reichen aus?
Drei reichen aus. Heutzutage haben sie vier, weil so ein bisschen Überlappung, gerade bei Atlantik zum Beispiel, ist gut. Aber damals hat man sich mit dreien, das waren die 70er, zufrieden gegeben. Und die haben dann analoge Audio-Verbindungen zur Verfügung gestellt.
Das war dann wahrscheinlich alles noch so handvermittelt, oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also geostationierter Orbit, also 36.000 Kilometer entfernt, wurden diese Satelliten dann positioniert. Drei einmal rundherum, sodass sie sich quasi so im Dreieck gegenseitig sehen konnten und damit mehr oder weniger die ganze Erde abdecken.
Genau.
Also so richtig die ganze Erde, reicht das so komplett? Na gut, also ich meine in den Polarregionen, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, da kommen wir später noch dazu. Die Polarregionen sind eben vom geostationierten Orbit nicht so doll erreichbar. Man kommt bis zum 80. Breitengrad.
Aber das ist ja dann sozusagen schon mal so 99 Prozent der Schifffahrt.
Genau, der kommerzielle Schifffahrt ist innerhalb des Bereichs. In Europa hat man dann mit den Marex-Satelliten, die ist er nachgelegt im Anfang der 80er.
Marex.
Marex. Das ist auch ein total entsprechendes Alkohol.
Das heißt, man hat schon gleich gemerkt, das ist eine tolle Idee. Machen wir mal. Und das waren dann auch geostationäre Satelliten.
Maritime European Communication Satellite. Das waren so ganz stupide Satelliten, die einfach nur, das ist ein Stapel Wanderfeldröhren im Weltraum, wo man Solarpanels dran gemacht hat, damit die einen Strom bekommen.
Was ist eine Wanderfeldröhre?
Das ist alte Röhrentechnik, wird auch heutzutage noch verwendet, weil es relativ unempfindlich ist im Weltraum. Das ist aller möglichen Strahlung ausgesetzt. Verstärkt Funk. Du steckst auf der einen Seite Funk rein und auf der anderen Seite fällt verstärkt das Funksignal wieder raus.
Lauffeldröhre, sagt man auch. Das heißt, die Signale werden dadurch verstärkt. Also im Prinzip eine Antenne, die ordentlich was raushaut. Weißt du, wie diese Kommunikation dann lief zu so einem Schiff? Ich meine, wenn das so analog ist, dann...
Das weiß ich nicht. Bei den Marek sind die Marek tatsächlich nicht...
Aber ich meine, wie kann das funktioniert haben? Im Prinzip ist es ja, man hat einen Kanal nach oben. Weiß nicht, ob man da mehr als einen hat. Wie viele Leute konnten da gleichzeitig kommunizieren? Und dann wird das ja im Prinzip über den ganzen Planeten ausgesendet, dieses Signal.
Genau, also jeweils über einen Drittel des Planeten.
Das heißt, da kann ja dann im Prinzip auch immer nur einer gleichzeitig kommunizieren.
Die haben einen Frequenzbereich von 5 MHz, glaube ich, gehabt, indem sie da kommuniziert haben. Schiffssatellit war im Bereich 1,5 Gigahertz und Bodenstationensatellit bei 6,4. Da hat sich auch seitdem nicht mehr doll viel geändert. Also das ist auch heute noch so, dass der Bereich 1,5, 1,6 Gigahertz dafür verwendet wird. Und da ist da wahrscheinlich Duplex-Audio-Verbindungen analog gehabt. Das war das, was dann auch später Inmar sagt, was eben aus den zwei unterschiedlichen Projekten entstanden ist. Bei der ersten möglich kommerziellen Generation der Satelliten, die Anfang der 90er dann die ersetzt haben, da hatten sie dann vier Stück. Und da hat es dann auch tatsächlich Telefone, die im Prinzip wie analoge Mobiltelefone die Satelliten dazu genutzt haben, mit einer Bodenstation zu sprechen. Und da konnte man dann auch richtig wählen. Du musst allerdings wissen, wo der jeweilige Teilnehmer zu Hause ist, weil oder gerade unterwegs ist, weil du halt das Problem hattest, dass da vier verschiedene Satelliten da sind. Du musst also immer wissen, im Empfangsbereich, von welchem Satellit ist dein Teilnehmer. Und hast dann dementsprechend die Landesvorwahl plus 871 für den Atlantik Ost, plus 874 für den Atlantik West, 872 Pazifik, 873 Indischer Ozean. Also musst du halt ungefähr wissen, wo dein Gesprächspartner ist. Und dann den entsprechenden Satelliten vorwählen und dann die Rufnummer. Dann hat das Telefon geklingelt.
Hast du da irgendwelche Erkenntnisse darüber, wie gut diese Qualität war? Ich meine, das dürfte ja erstmal eine riesige Latenz gewesen sein. Wenn man so in geostationären Orbit geht, dann muss das Signal ja auf jeden Fall schon mal so mindestens 72.000, wahrscheinlich sogar noch deutlich mehr Kilometer zurücklegen.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich bei geostationären Satellitentelefonen das Problem, dass das eher so ein bisschen Gegensprechen ist. Man muss das gegenüber ausreden lassen. Das ist ein bisschen mühsam. Die Audioqualität, naja, es ist halt eine analoge Verbindung, die einmal in den Weltraum wieder zurückgeht. Kann man sich jetzt streiten, ob das bei analoger Satellitentelefonie besser war als bei der digitalen, wo dann die Sprache bis zur Unkenntlichkeit zerkomprimiert wird? Aber, hey, sie haben da immerhin Faxe übertragen. Und später mit noch den analogen Inmarsat-Satelliten-Modem-Verbindungen mit 19,2, mit 19K2 aufgebaut.
Nicht schlecht.
Irgendwann wollten sie dann auch mal ihre Wetterdaten haben. Und was ist dann eher liegender als sie einfach aufs Schiff zu fachsen?
Cool, eigentlich. Ich meine, was für ein Aufwand, aber das ist natürlich dann sau teuer. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Schiffe dann gleich voll drauf eingestiegen sind. Ich meine, hatten die dann sozusagen so einen unmittelbaren Vorteil davon, dass sie gesagt haben, ja hurra?
Für den grundlegenden Dienst auf jeden Fall, weil neben den Wetterkarten, die da durchaus wichtig sind, um eben nicht unterzugehen, hat das auch für das Global Maritime Distress and Safety System eine wichtige Rolle gespielt. Du möchtest ja als Schiff, wenn dir irgendwas passiert, einen Notruf absetzen können und ab einer gewissen Größe war da so ein Inmarsat-Terminal irgendwann nicht mehr wegzudenken.
Aber es war dann wahrscheinlich eher so ein Rack, was man dann irgendwo reingeschoben hat.
Ja, die waren schon relativ früh, relativ klein. Hat man in den 80ern, Ende 80er, in Kofferformen bekommen, hat es da so einen Koffer. Und in den früheren so eine Regenschirmanterne, die man auspacken konnte und Richtung Satellitgrub ausrichten. Und später war die Antenne dann als Panel-Antenne in den Kofferdeckel integriert. Also muss man sich vorstellen wie ein Aktenkoffer mit einem Telefon drin. Und wo auch immer man den Aktenkoffer innerhalb der 80 Grad nördlicher, südlicher Breite aufgeklappt und in die richtige Richtung positioniert hat, konnte man das Telefon, was da drin ist, zum Telefonieren verwenden.
Aber das muss man sozusagen schon nochmal so explizit tun. Die haben jetzt nicht sich automatisch da den Satellit ausgerichtet oder so?
Auf den Schiffen ja. Da hattest du Sattschlüsseln, die sich automatisch positionieren. Ist ja auch ein bisschen Seegang und so. Die führen das dann nach. Aber bei InMarsat ist es tatsächlich so, dass bei den 1,5 Gigahertz und der geringen Datenrate oder dem nicht so großen Anspruch an... Man muss es nicht so präzise ausrichten wie eine Fernsehschüssel. Bei so einer Fernsehsatteliten-Schüssel hast du unglaublich hohe Datenraten, die eine sehr hohe Anforderung an die Signalgüte haben. Bei so einem Satellitentelefon, auch den früheren, war jetzt die Ausrichtung auf plus minus ein paar Grad nicht so wichtig.
Hauptsache, man zielt so etwa an die richtige Stelle auf dem Himmel.
Genau.
Und das heißt, aus diesem Marsat und... Das europäische Marex. Aus den beiden dann zusammen ist in Marsat gegründet worden?
Na in Marsat war der logische Nachfolger der zwei Systeme.
Okay. Aber dann gab es auch nur noch ein System für alle sozusagen.
Genau, da gab es nur noch ein System für alle. Das wurde dann auch privatisiert, weil die Nachfrage immer größer geworden war. Das ist nicht nur so eine Basisdienstleistung. Wir wollen, dass unsere Schiffe irgendwie kommunizieren können, sondern dass auch natürlich an Land Regel genutzt wurde in Regionen, wo du halt kein Telefon hast.
Aber es war halt alles analog.
Das war alles analog in dieser ersten Generation. Also wenn du nicht gerade den Analogkanal dazu genutzt hast, um ein Faxgerät zu betreiben, ein Modem anzuschließen oder Telex.
Ja, na gut, ich meine, das ist im Prinzip das Äquivalent zu dem damals verbreiteten analogen Telefonanschluss. Und das damit zu machen ist ja eigentlich auch ganz sinnvoll, weil es ist halt universell. Letzten Endes hat sich der Satellit selber ja gar nicht groß drum gekümmert, was da jetzt eigentlich für ein Signal anlag, sondern es ging eigentlich nur noch darum, das direkte analoge Signal umzuleiten. Kann man sich das Ding dann eigentlich so vorstellen wie so einen großen Spiegel im Weltraum, der eigentlich nichts anderes macht als das Signal, breitflächig zu verteilen? Muss er ja nicht mit einer unglaublichen Energie senden, um wirklich dann die ganze Erde ausreichend zu beschicken?
Ich weiß nicht, wie es damals war, aber die aktuellen InMAR-Satelliten gehören zu den stärksten mit 1800 Watt No-Power in die Antenne rein.
Und die Terminals am Boden 1800 Watt in die Antenne. Also wie so eine Baumaschine, wie ein Staubsauger.
Die Telefone am Boden, das glaube ich im Bereich von 1-2 Watt. Viel wird da mit Antennengewinn auf Satellitenseite wieder gut gemacht. Und eben dadurch, dass man einen relativ schmalbandigen, ja, also du überträgst da jetzt nicht ein Videosignal, sondern ein ganz schmales Audiosignal. Je weniger Daten man hat, desto einfacher.
Also man hat diese große Bandbreite, diesen kompletten reservierten Frequenzbereich. Und jedes Gespräch kriegt quasi so einen Slot zugeteilt. War das dann sozusagen eine dynamische Zuteilung?
Das war dann eine dynamische Zuteilung, ja.
Das heißt, das, aber wo lag denn dann sozusagen diese Logik der Zuteilung? Also dann ruft man quasi da in dieser Zentrale an und will halt mit einem Schiff reden.
Und kriegt dann von der Zentrale einen Kanal zugeteilt.
Zugeteilt, aus dem man dann sendet und wo er weiß, das Schiff auf welchem Kanal es dann sozusagen empfangen soll. Das Schiff, das dümpelt ja dann erstmal so vor sich hin und kann vorher nicht wissen, auf welchem Kanal es überhaupt angefunkt wird. Dann gab es wahrscheinlich auch so einen Master-Vermittlungs-Kanal.
Genau, das ist wie bei analogen Mobilfunknetzen auch. Wo du halt einen Kanal hast, auf dem du hörst und auf dem dir dann mitgeteilt werden kann. Da ist ein Anruf für dich hier. Kanal so und so, Kanal so und so. Viel Spaß beim Telefonieren.
Also so ein Kontrollkanal.
Genau.
Der dann aber auch, ja, weiß nicht, ob der dann auch so analog sein kann.
Nee, das war dann schon digital. Das ging dann ja weiter. Also dieser erste analoge Dienst, der lief zwar noch ziemlich lange. Das glaube ich sogar Anfang dieses Jahrtausends, aber wurde schnell auch vom Bedarf her durch digitale Dienste ersetzt. So einer der ersten war da in Maserat M, Mini M, Mini M war ja kleinere Terminals, wo man dann auch ISDN-Kanäle digital vermittelt bekommen hat. Sündhaft teuer für 20 Mark damals die Minute, 10 Euro.
Noch in den 80ern oder was? Das war Anfang der 90er. Also als das mit ISDN losging. Wie ISDN oder basierte das dann im Prinzip auf denselben Ideen und Protokollen?
Das ist bei Satellitenkommunikation immer so eine Sache. Die schneiden den Protokollstapel irgendwo durch und sagen, wir reichen den ISDN-Kanal über unsere Technik weiter. Alles, was wir darunter machen, ist dann auf das Satellitensystem angepasst.
Aber man hat sich daran orientiert.
Genau.
Weil das war ja im Prinzip die große Errungenschaft der 80er-Jahre, dass man diese ganze Digitale Telefonie auf eine komplett andere Ebene gestellt hat und ISDN versucht hat, da universell alles zu erreichen, was auch geklappt hat mit Ausnahmen der USA.
Ja, auch da hat es, glaube ich, ISDN durchaus für kommerzielle Anwendungen, überhaupt Radiostationen zum Beispiel haben ISDN verwendet in den USA, um Zuspielungen, so Musiktaxi nennt sich das. Da weiß ich zumindest aus der US-amerikanischen Community, da haben sie ISDN verwendet und zwar sehr gerne. Furchtbar teuer, weil war halt ein Nischending, aber das war so bevor IP Breiten verfügbar in garantierten hohen Bandbreiten, hat man da ganz gerne ISDN für verwendet.
Genau, da haben wir ja auch schon in anderen Sendungen drüber geredet, soll jetzt gar nicht hier so der Fokus sein, aber das muss man sich mal wieder klar machen, dass eigentlich so diese ganze europäische und amerikanische Entwicklung an der Stelle so ein bisschen entkoppelt war, weil einfach in den USA durch diese Größe des Landes einfach dieser Druck da nicht so da war, während Deutschland so, ja hurra, Digitalisierung, jetzt stellen wir mal alles um, das einfach mal durchgezogen hat. Und dann haben halt die Amerikaner später mit DSL geantwortet und dann standen wir da. Gut, zurück zu INMASAT.
Ein Einschub zur Musiktaxi noch, zu dem ISDN. Das war halt auch ein Basistienst, der für Berichterstattung sehr gerne verwendet wurde, dass man eben seinen ISDN-Kanal, unser Musiktaxi über den Satelliten benutzt, wenn du irgendwo einen Korrespondenten hast für einen Radiosender oder sowas, der sein Audio beitragt, dann konnten die über INMASAT in hoher Gesprächskualität sendefähig telefonieren.
Also jetzt über das INMASAT M?
Über INMASAT MINIM, ja. Oder M, ja.
MINIM.
MINIM hat, glaube ich, gar kein 64 Kilobit gehabt. Frag mich was leichteres. Das ist auch bei denen sehr schwierig, weil die haben zum einen die Produktnamen, das ist irgendwie INMASAT A, B, C, dann für Telex, MINIM, weiß der Fuchs, die Technologie drunter, sieht dann wieder anders aus.
Gut, aber man kann festhalten, das hat mehr oder weniger analog gestartet, mit vielleicht einem kleinen digitalen Vermittlungskanal, der aber letzten Endes nicht sehr viel mehr gemacht hat, als Klingeling gesagt. Und hier ist die Telefonnummer, und wer will denn das mal annehmen? Wahrscheinlich hätte dann jedes Gerät irgendwie auch jeden Call annehmen können. Nehmen wir mal an, die Entscheidung, wer annimmt, das ist dann auf Empfängerseite quasi gefallen.
Ja, auch mit dem richtigen Empfänger konnte man damals die ganzen Gespräche problemlos mitverfolgen, ohne irgendwie großen Aufwand zu betreiben, weil das war halt einfach Radio, was da vom Himmel fällt, halt auf einer anderen Frequenz, aber analog ist es auch.
Das erreicht dir auch das Land. Man brauchte eigentlich nur eine Schüssel aufstellen, sich auf diesen Frequenzbereich reinmachen, sich dann das entsprechende Band aussuchen, und dann konnte man hören, was die da alles so mit einer Quatsch gab.
Ja, brauchst du noch nicht mal eine Schüssel, weil das war ja entsprechend stark für mobile Tränen. Du brauchst im Prinzip nur eine kleine Inmarsat-Antenne aus einem Koffer und abgehilft sie.
Gut, dabei ist es aber doch nicht geblieben. Also Inmarsat gibt es ja auch heute noch als Netz und als Betreiber, nur dass diese Netze sich halt jetzt mehrfach erneuert haben. Wann war denn sozusagen das Ende dieser ersten Generation? Da gab es ja nur Inmarsat sozusagen.
Ja, das war Anfang der 90er und dann auch im Laufe der 90er als der Bedarf für digitale Kommunikation da war und auch die entsprechende Kohle und sowas. Da war ja richtig Aufbruchsstimmung. Und eins dieser Projekte, die im Rahmen dieser Aufbruchsstimmung mit 1,8 Milliarden waren das, glaube ich, haben sie damals investiert, war das Iridium-System. Da hat man sich nämlich gedacht, Satelliten ist toll, geostationär, wie wäre das denn, wenn wir in einem niedrigeren Erdorbit unserer Satelliten aufhängen und darüber dann kommunizieren. Da haben wir bessere Laufzeiten, wir brauchen weniger Sendeleistungen. Nun haben wir dann das Problem, dass wir damit nicht mit vier Satelliten arbeiten können, weil die sind ja nicht mehr fix an einem Ort. Geh stationäre Umlaufbahnen bedeutet, du hast einen Satelliten, der steht immer da oben. Du guckst in die Richtung, hast du deinen Satelliten. Der bewegt sich nicht. Wenn man das jetzt in einem niedrigeren Erdorbit zuhause haben möchte und iridium hat sich dafür 700 Kilometer entschieden, dann siehst du den Satelliten halt nur so alle 100 Minuten irgendwo. Eine Umrundung von so einem Satelliten in der Umlaufbahn sind 100 Minuten. Das heißt, man braucht viele davon. Im Vorher von iridium war es im ersten Konzept 77.
Deswegen noch der Name?
Ich kriege das noch durcheinander.
Nein, 77.
77.
Weil das ja die Ordnungszahl von iridium im Plurodensystem ist.
Das ursprüngliche Konzept waren glaube ich 66 Satelliten plus nochmal 11 Spares. Also sie brauchen de facto 66 Satelliten und haben 11 Spares. Da hatten sie sich dann überlegt, nennen wir es doch nach dem 66. Element. Sie haben es nachgeguckt, Dysprosium.
Ach so, so rum.
Was heißt denn Dysprosium? Hard to reach. Schwer erreichbar. Zählen wir einfach die Spares mit, sind 77. Iridium klingt toll.
Okay. Und am Ende brauchten sie aber gar nicht so viele.
Am Ende brauchten sie, kommt drauf an welches Ende du meinst. Satelliten haben ja eine Lebensdauer. Also es war schon ganz gut, dass sie die 77 oben hatten. Die Spares haben sie gebraucht. Das lief alles ein bisschen länger als eine Erfolgsgeschichte. Aber für eine 100% Abdeckung haben sie eben die 66 Satelliten gebraucht.
Aber das Modell, was man ja sozusagen vorher hatte mit den drei oder vier stationären Satelliten, wurde jetzt quasi ersetzt durch niedrig fliegende Satelliten, die dadurch ja auch schneller fliegen müssen, also sonst einfach runterfallen. Und deswegen zischen die eigentlich die ganze Zeit an einem vorbei. Und damit man auch immer einen sieht, brauchen wir einfach mehr davon. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man jetzt wie bei Inmarsat immer nur mit einem kommuniziert. Dann könnte man ja immer nur maximal eine Stunde reden und dann wäre er weg.
Das war die Herausforderung tatsächlich an das System. Deswegen, dass auch bis heute für die Zeit damals eine unglaubliche Engineering-Leistung war. Diesen Handover-Prozess für den User, also kannst du in ihrem Telefon halt benutzen, eine Stunde telefonieren, hast du in der Zwischenzeit mit ein paar Dutzend Satelliten, die an dir vorbeigeflogen sind, und hast davon nicht doll viel gemerkt.
Also, was heißt Handover? Das heißt, man telefoniert tatsächlich. Ich hab ein Telefon, ich sag, ich will jetzt hier mit irgendjemand reden, dann wird mir so ein Satellit ausgesucht, der quasi gerade über mich rüberfliegt. Und mit dem, der wird dann quasi mit den Signalen beschickt.
Das ist eben genau bei ihrem Medium das Ding. Also du siehst halt alle paar Minuten einen neuen Satelliten und sie mussten irgendwie hinbekommen, dass du nicht nur mit dem neuen Satelliten telefonieren kannst, sondern dass deine Sprache auch wieder da ankommt. Deswegen haben sie in diese Konstellationen, man muss sich das so vorstellen, wie eine Perlenkette an der Satelliten, den Globus vor Augen hat, dann hat man da sechs Perlenketten, an denen diese Satelliten einmal von Norden nach Süden aufgereiht sind. Das sechsmal. Und die bewegen sich dann über die Pole. Also die Inklinationen des Orbits sind fast 90 Grad. Das sind glaube ich 86,7 Grad. Das heißt, die umrunden die Erde, Nordpol, Südpol, Nordpol, Südpol.
Alle?
Alle. Jeweils immer elf Stück hintereinander pro orbital plane, also pro per Ankette. Um dann das Gespräch zu vermitteln, können sie auch untereinander sprechen. Jeder dieser elf Satelliten in so einer orbital plane hat zu den zwei anderen, vor ihm und hinter ihm, einen Funk-Link.
Und... Wie schnell?
Zehn Megabit. Also wir reden Ende 80er, Anfang 90er. Das war schon...
Eine Menge. Da war man schon froh, wenn es zehn Megabit am eigenen PC funktioniert hat, so über Ethernet.
Und die haben dafür auch im Satelliten, das ist eben das Besondere, was InMars so nicht hatte, haben sie auch nicht gebraucht. Aber da mussten sie im Satelliten Gespräche vermitteln. Deswegen hat das ProLink, der nicht nur zum Satelliten vor einem und hinter einem in der Perlen Schnur, sondern auch nach links und nach rechts, also das vier Inter-Satellite-Links, die jeweils mit zehn Megabit zwischen den Satelliten vermitteln. Und um das hinzubekommen, hat das ProSatellit einen Motorola PPC 200 MHz CPU. Die nur dafür da war, diese... oder da ist diese zehn Megabit Kommunikationsverkehr hin und her zu schieben. Dann hat das noch einen weiteren für das, was so ein Satellite tut, um aufzubleiben, Stationkeeping und so weiter, Attitude Control. Und einen für restliche Kommunikation.
Das heißt, ich muss mir das so vorstellen, dass man quasi mal zu der Erde, und dann hat man so erste Perlenkette, geht irgendwie über Berlin, nächste geht irgendwie über Moskau, nächste geht irgendwo über Asien etc. und so weiter, bis man quasi einmal komplett die Erde so wie so ein Käfig sozusagen eingefangen hat. Und alle kommunizieren innerhalb ihres Orbits mit den anderen, die auf derselben Linie fliegen. Aber wenn es nötig ist, nach links und rechts weiterzureichen, dann geben sie das sozusagen auch in die andere Kette quer rüber.
Das heißt, wenn zwei Leute über ihre die umtelefonieren, dann kann es sein, wenn sie nah beieinander sind, dass es über den gleichen Satelliten geht. Wenn sie ein bisschen weiter entfernt sind, dann geht es halt über ein, zwei Satelliten, bis das Gespräch die Daten da ankommen, wo sie wieder runter müssen und dann geht es da runter.
Wenn ich jetzt in Afrika auf dem Äquator stehe und ich möchte gerne mit jemandem in Asien auf dem Äquator stehen, dann muss ich ja erstmal so drei oder ungefähr drei Perlenketten, zwei bis drei Perlenketten quasi weiterkommen. Würde das dann, also ist das dann sozusagen tatsächlich so, ich kommuniziere mit dem, der über mir ist und der kommuniziert dann quasi am Äquator entlang zu dem Nächsten?
Das Schicke ist, du fährst eine Rufnummer und hast dann deinen Gegenüber dran.
Ja, ich versuche ja nur, den Signal aufzuziehen.
Der komplette Signallauf ist für dich, das funktioniert halt einfach.
Aber ist jetzt nicht so, dass da noch irgendeine Bodenstation oder so zum Einsatz kommt, dass es sozusagen in diesem Netz hochgeschickt wird?
Die Bodenstation brauchst du nur, um die Telefonnummer aufzulösen, über welchen Satelliten telefoniert der Mensch gerade.
Genau, aber das ist ja eigentlich auch schon so, was man auch im Kopf behalten muss, dass die Satellitentelefonie ja möglichst unabhängig sein will von irgendeiner Infrastruktur auf der Erde. Selbst wenn alles brennt und irgendwie überall Trump regiert, dass man dann immer noch von dem einen Land ins andere kommt, quasi mit so einer direkten Punkt-zu-Punkt-Verbindung.
Genau, wobei du natürlich die Bodenstation brauchst, um die Vermittlung des Gesprächs zu machen. Also völlig unabhängig davon ist das System nicht. Aber zumindest werden deine Daten nicht ohne Not weiter weggeschickt, als es sein muss, geschweige denn in die stationäre Erdumlaufbahn. Was sich auch in deutlich angenehmeren Gesprächslaufzeiten, also kannst du dich mit einem Gegenüber mal direkt eine Konversation betreiben und musst nicht gegen sprechen.
Wie muss man sich diese Latenzen vorstellen bei dem alten Inmarsatz-System?
Das ist doch schon eine halbe Sekunde.
Eine halbe Sekunde?
Eine halbe Sekunde.
Und wenn man es jetzt auf Iridium überträgt? Also das ist ja nicht keine, ne?
Ich würde jetzt sagen, 200-300 Millisekunden oder so.
Das ist schon erträglich.
Das ist spielbar angenehmer, ja.
Aber das hatte nicht so einen richtig guten Start, dieses Iridium-System, weil das war ein bisschen teuer, oder?
Ja, mit den 1,8 Milliarden war das erstmal ein großer Batzen, der wieder reingeholt werden musste. Und bei Preisen von, glaube ich, 15 Dollar pro Minute hat das damals...
Klingt aber gar nicht so teuer, wenn man bedenkt, dass sie dafür 77 Satelliten starten mussten.
Jaja, also das...
Die haben sie aber nicht einzeln gestartet.
Die haben sie nicht einzeln gestartet, nee. Das ist immer so schubweise gegangen. Das war eine absolute Tour de force. Also, wie gesagt, der Engineering-Aufwand damals war erstaunlich. Die haben auch ganz viele Patente angemeldet. Und spannenderweise den Großteil davon nicht auf irgendwelche Kommunikationstechniken. Kommunikation war eher so weniger das Problem bei ihrem Regium. Klar, das musste irgendwie implementiert werden, aber das war... Kannte man schon vom Boden. So guckt man sich halt seine Rahmenbedingungen an, baut einen Kommunikationsprotokoll und gut ist. Was eine Pioniersleistung war, war die Fertigung. Da hat Motorola, die das System gebaut haben, den Engineer abgeworben, der die erste Macintosh Factory, also die erste Automated Mac Factory gebaut hat, um ihm die Herausforderung zu übertragen. Ja, wir wollen jetzt Satelliten herstellen. Ein paar weniger als Macs, aber auch möglichst wenig Aufwand reinstecken. Ergebnis des Ganzen war, dass sie dann tatsächlich alle 4,3 Tage einen Satelliten am Start hatten mit einer Entwicklungszeit von unter einem Monat pro O-Satellite.
Das ist unglaublich. Man muss sich klar machen, dass im Raumfahrtbereich fast überhaupt nichts in Serie hergestellt wird. Meistens sind die Satelliten immer absolute Prototypen bzw. immer wieder neue Pionierleistungen. Die nächste Generation baut man dann anders und neu. Es muss natürlich auch noch mal komplett anders getestet werden. Dadurch steigen diese Kosten immer so enorm. Das war dann im Prinzip die erste wirkliche Raumfahrt-Serie in Produktion.
Ja, und auch die Zeit von so einem Projekt, wenn du sagst, baue noch mal Satelliten, dann sitzt man an so einem Ding ein paar Monate dran, bis das fertig ist und da alle Schrauben festgedreht sind. Und das auf unter einem Monat, also das in Wochen fertig zu haben, ist schon eine Leistung, insbesondere unter dem Gesichtspunkt, dass die Dinge immer noch funktionieren, also ein Großteil davon. Der erste Iridium-Start, das war vor 20 Jahren, 2017, 97. Da sind die ersten Satelliten draufgeschossen worden. Und von denen sind immer noch welche im Betrieb.
Einer hat es ja zerhauen, ne? Einer von denen ist ja, glaube ich, mit dieser alten russischen Weltraumschrott zusammengestoßen.
Ja, da gab es so ein bisschen Space Palliard, weil der niedrige Erdorbit, der ist halt sehr, also da fliegt viel Müll auch rum. Und je größer so eine Konstellation ist, umso wahrscheinlicher wird es, dass da mal irgendwas kollidiert. Weswegen so Satelliten auch heutzutage deorbited werden. Das hatten sie auch bei Iridium, als das dann sich rausstellte, dass die 1,8 Milliarden sowohl nicht mehr reinkommen. Sie haben gesagt, okay, lass mal die Satelliten verglühen.
Also sie haben alles gestartet und dann ist in die Kohle ausgegangen?
Genau, und haben was festgestellt. Ist unrealistisch, dass das reinkommt. Ja, und mussten dann Chapter 11, das ist ein USA-Konkurs anmelden, war eine der größten Pleiten in der damaligen Geschichte.
Motorola steckt ja dahinter. Genau.
Und? Die hatten auch das Konzept von Aerion, war auch völlig astronomisch. Sie hatten an mehreren Orten auf der Welt Ground Stations, also muss man sich so vorstellen, das ist so ein kleines Radom, unter dem eine bewegliche Satellitenschüsse ist, weil die Satelliten bewegen sich ja alle. Und davon drei Stück, die jeweils unterschiedliche Satelliten anpeilen und mit denen dann Daten austauschen, bis der Satellit wieder hinter dem Horizont verschwindet und die Satellitenschüsse sich auf den nächsten Satelliten ausrichtet. Das tun diese drei Schüsse in 24-7. Die stehen da in dieser Ground Station und sprechen die ganze Zeit mit den Satelliten, die über sie hinwegfliegen. Die Satelliten vermitteln das Gespräch dann weiter untereinander bis zu demjenigen, der das Telefon in der Hand hält. Und das Setup mit diesen drei Schüsseln, das hatten sie jetzt nicht nur einmal oder zweimal, sondern die hatten davon knappes Dutzend über den Globus verteilt, weil man ja möchte, dass das Gespräch möglichst lokal zugestellt wird. Und das wurde dann jeweils über lokale Motorola-Dependenzen oder Iridium-Dependenzen auch vertrieben. Also du konntest dir eine Karte von Iridium Africa kaufen, du konntest dir eine SIM-Karte von also die unterschiedlichen, für die unterschiedlichen Gateways. Und das war halt ein zusätzlicher Overhead, der einfach gigantisch war.
Weil das muss ja alles betrieben werden, das muss Leute sein, das muss irgendwie in voller Verfügbarkeit sein. Wenn die Dinger sich die ganze Zeit bewegen, dann kann man die ja auch mal nicht so eben reparieren, sondern dann muss das Ding irgendwie runterfahren und dann muss das irgendwie über andere Downlink-Routen.
Und noch dazu kam, dass es damals Roaming-Abkommen gab. Also sie mussten auch zu allen Mobilfunknetzen, zu allen terrestrischen, die ihren Kunden ermöglichen wollten, ihr Iridium-Satellitennetz mitzunutzen, Verbindungen unterhalten. Also da hat das nicht nur dein globales Netz an Groundstations, die die Satelliten beschickt haben, sondern du musstest auch mit den ganzen Carriers rund um den Erdbeil, die ihren, ja, so ein TD-1 oder Vodafone, weiß der Fuchs, konntest du deine SIM-Karte nehmen, in so ein Iridium-Phone einlegen und lostelefonieren. Für, naja, entsprechend mehr Geld. Das hat sich auch nie gelohnt, weil ja, die Leute, die es gebraucht haben, haben dann halt sich ein Iridium-SIM geholt. Ich glaube nicht, dass der Roaming-Traffic bei Iridium jemals signifikant war.
Kann es sein, dass so Motorola ein bisschen davon ausgegangen ist, dass die da so the next big thing haben und dass sie sozusagen diese eigentliche Dynamik, die in den normalen GSM-Pobilfunknetzen gesteckt haben, so gar nicht gesehen haben?
Ich glaube damals hat niemand an die EO-Roaming-Verordnung geglaubt, dass jemals so was passieren würde, dass halt Roaming tatsächlich günstig wird und die Leute mit ihren Mobiltelefonen kontinentübergreifend unterwegs sind. Und zum anderen haben sie den Bedarf kolossal überschätzt, an Orten zu telefonieren, wo es keinen Mobilfunknetz gibt, weil die Orte immer weniger wurden. Also die Lücke aufzufüllen, zu sagen, da wird halt kein Mobilfunknetz ausgebaut, dann nutzt man iridium mit seiner SIM-Karte im Roaming.
Afrika zum Beispiel nehme ich mal an. Ich glaube, da waren ja einige überrascht, dass da das Mobil so boomt. Genau, weil gerade nämlich alles andere nie funktioniert hat. Schwuppdebub war Afrika auf einmal gecovert.
Und das natürlich dann zu ganz anderen Raten als Satellitenfunk.
Das heißt, man hatte jetzt eine Infrastruktur gebaut, die eigentlich keine, also nicht keine Kundschaft hatte, aber deren Kundschaft teilweise entweder mit Inmarsat noch glücklich und zufrieden war für ihren Bedarf. Und so, ja, Iridium nicht unbedingt brauchte. Und diejenigen, die immer so der coole Telefonier-Jet-Set sind und alles haben müssen, die gibt es zwar, aber die waren nicht so in den Zahlen vorhanden, um die 1,8 Milliarden wieder reinzuholen und was auch immer dann noch so die Betriebskosten waren. Genau.
Es gibt dann halt noch einen anderen Jet-Set, der sich leisten kann, durch die Gegend zu fliegen und zu telefonieren, was auch ein signifikanter Kunde von Iridium war, das US-Militär. Die fanden das total großartig, dass sie den Leuten nicht mehr irgendwelche Funkgeräte oder irgendwelche Militärsatelliten mit großer Regenschirmschüssel und so, sondern denen einfach mal so ein naja, wie groß ist es? Ich hab eins vor mir. Etwas kleiner als eine mate Flasche. Ungefähr so breit und dick wie eine mate Flasche, aber kleiner. Von der Höhe her.
Aber wenn man diese Antenne ausklappt, dann geht's aber schon so ein bisschen in die Richtung, ne?
Und die haben das sehr gerne genutzt, weil zum einen ist es Technologie, die global verfügbar ist, und zum anderen hast du halt genau den Vorteil, dass dein Signal rauf geht, rüber geht, runter geht, und du nicht noch irgendwo zusätzliche Infrastruktur hast, die du nicht brauchst. Also es war schon...
Das heißt, die waren auch von Anfang an Kunde?
Die waren von Anfang an Kunde, ja. Die hatten sogar, bei Endgeräten für Satellitenkommunikation gibt es ja nicht so doll viel Auswahl, weil das ist im Gegensatz zu GSM, UMTS, jetzt kein Massending, gibt es halt immer so zwei, drei Geräte Auswahl. Das, was du jetzt in der Hand hast, ist ein Motorola-Gerät, oh Wunder, mit einer Klappe hinten. Kann man auch rausnehmen. Das ist ein Modul, das ein Modul, was ein GSM-Modem ist. Das bedeutet, man kann mit der SIM-Karte, die im Telefon eingelegt ist, sich auch in das GSM-Netz einbuchen. Das ist so ein schwarzes Kästchen, was man hinten in...
Das ist nochmal so ein Huckepack-Telefon.
Genau, Huckepack auf das Telefon raufklickt mit einer eigenen Antenne, wo du GSM mit nutzen kannst. Auf Basis derselben Technik, auf dem selben Formfaktor gab es auch Verschlüsselungs-Huckepackgeräte. Das heißt, das Militär konnte mit eigener Krypto und diesen Telefonen untereinander Verschlüsse telefonieren.
Das fanden die bestimmt richtig geil.
Das fanden die richtig geil, ja.
Vor allem fand ich es nicht so richtig geil, als dann Motorola gesagt hat, jetzt lassen wir die Dinger mal wieder im Meer verschwinden.
Genau, dann haben sie mich rumgeguckt. Was haben wir da? Wir haben Inmarsat. Das ist ja mittlerweile eine britische Firma. Das wurde privatisiert. Was haben wir sonst noch? So ein Konsortium, was, ein anderes Netz? Globestar, das kommen wir später noch zu. Und die Araber haben da noch so eine Telefonie. Satelliten, wir hätten dieses Seridium, das ist schon nicht praktisch. Wie viel ist denn da? Also wie viel braucht er denn?
Das heißt, sie sind dann einfach mal zum Motorola gegangen und haben ihnen ein Angebot gemacht, was sie nicht ablehnen konnten?
Ja, im Wesentlichen sind, das ist das US-Mediterium gewesen, das die offene Rechnung sei. Heute quasi ein Flatrate-Contract. Die haben so und so vier SIM-Karten, bezahlen dafür eben so viel Kohle, wie das System gebraucht hat. Und Eridium in der zweiten Iteration nach der Pleite ist heute profitabel. Die hatten auch schon ganz von Anfang, damit treiben sie natürlich weiterhin ihre eigene Bodenstation. Die steht auf Hawaii. In einer Militärbasis auf Hawaii stehen auch drei so, Eridium, Radome, und die telefonieren quasi komplett unabhängig vom kommerziellen Verkehr, der über das Eridium-Netz geht, über ihr eigenes Gateway.
Sie haben sozusagen ihren eigenen Uplink, wo dann gar nicht erst Motorola irgendwas mit zu tun hat.
Ja, da steht Motorola-Technik drin und lustigerweise Siemens-EWSD. Also als Vermittlungsstelle in den Eridium-Gateways steht das elektronische Wehrsystem digital von Siemens, weil da war halt the Business, so wenn man Telefonie digital haben wollte damals. Das haben sie mittlerweile, glaube ich, steht da jetzt, ich weiß es nicht, aber das haben sie ersetzt. Also im neuen System, was jetzt gerade raufgeschossen wird, werden die EWSDs, glaube ich, irgendwann fliegen.
Aber grundsätzlich, Iridium war das erste auch, also jetzt nicht nur ambitioniert in Bezug auf die Größenordnung, die hinderer Höhe, niedrige Relatenzen etc. Sondern es war halt auch das erste digital arbeitende System.
Na, Inmarsat hat schon auch digital gearbeitet. Also die Variante, die ISDN auch abgebildet hat, da kann man schon davon sprechen, dass das digital war. Aber so richtig digitales Switching im Orbit, das war ein First, auf jeden Fall. Noch ganz kurz zum zweiten Iridium. Die haben dann ihre ganzen Gateways abgeschaltet, bis auf ein Gateway in Tampa, Arizona, wo auch das Iridium SNOC steht, das Satellite Network Operations Center, von dem aus das ganze Netz geflogen wird sozusagen. Also die kümmern sich auch darum, dass Satelliten ausgetauscht werden, wenn irgendwo einer einen Bauchweh hat.
Was auch schon stattgefunden hat?
Was auch regelmäßig stattgefunden hat. Der Leiter von dem Betrieb hat mal in einem Video erzählt. Es gibt Satellite, wie ich es nenne die Dinge, es gibt SUVs, die wir mögen, die behalten sich wie Engel. Und dann gibt es welche, wo man schon weiß, das ist schon wieder der. Die haben auch ihre Pappenheimer. Also da hat schon jeder Satellite seine eigene Persönlichkeit und seinen Charakter. Und da gibt es durchaus welche, die dann ausgetauscht werden müssen. Das machen sie, indem sie die Satelliten aus dieser Ebene, in der sie da fliegen, den 700 Kilometer herausheben, in einen höheren oder niedrigeren Orbit.
Alle.
Einzelne. Also wenn es ein einzelner Satellit, wenn sich anzeichnet, dass der nicht mehr so doll lange hat, was für die natürlich total großartig ist, wenn man das vorher weiß. Weil so ein Iridium-Satellit, der hat, glaube ich, jetzt müsste ich lügen, nur 100 Kilogramm Fuel. Also Treibstoff. Und den Treibstoff, den verwendet man natürlich am liebsten dazu, um den Satelliten da zu haben. Also eigentlich verwendet man den echt. Also jedes Gramm Treibstoff, was sie verbrauchen, setzt die Lebensstoffe von so einem Satelliten runter. Weil wenn er keinen Treibstoff mehr hat, dann muss er deorbited werden, sprich runtergeschickt werden, zum verglühen. Weil er Traumschrott. Und deswegen sind sie mit dem Treibstoff äußerst vorsichtig. Aber wenn eben sich abzeichnet, dass ein Satellit in Beelde das Zeitliche segnet, dann gucken sie sich einen aus, der gerade nicht in Verwendung ist, also einen Spare, und schieben den an diese Position. Je früher sie Bescheid wissen, desto mehr Zeit haben sie, desto weniger Fuel brauchen sie. Was richtig kostspielig ist, ist die von einem Band in ein anderes Band drüber zu schieben. Weil da müssen sie nicht nur den Satelliten ein bisschen runter oder raufschicken und warten, bis er an die Position gedriftet ist, sondern da müssen sie ihn lateral, also nach links oder nach rechts, verschieben und auch an der Position, wenn er da angekommen ist, wieder abbremsen. Das verschlingt richtig viel Kraftstoff.
Aber dafür sind sozusagen diese Spares da. Die fliegen eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur mit und sind für den Fall da, dass einer in der jeweiligen Kette ausfällt. Aber dann muss ja die Anna ja auch irgendwie im Zweifelsfall, wenn man die jetzt mal so durchnummerieren, die Position dieser Satelliten und sagen wir mal, die Nummer drei schwächelt jetzt. Wo befindet sich denn dann dieser Spare eigentlich in dem Moment?
Das kommt halt darauf an, wo noch ein Spare über das Wendeglück befindet, der sich im gleichen Band. Und du brauchst den Spare einfach nur anheben oder runter senken, warten, bis er an der Position ist, den alten Satelliten durch den B-Aubitten runter schieben.
Ach so, durch das Absenken oder höher machen. Ach so, wenn man weiter rausgeht, wird man quasi langsamer. Genau. Ah, das heißt, er geht einfach mal hoch, die anderen fliegen vorbei und wenn die Stelle kommt, dann wieder runter und dann wird er einfach reingesenkt.
Genau.
Okay, aber wenn jetzt einer, wenn jetzt sozusagen eine komplette Kette keinen Spare mehr hat?
Dann muss ein Spare aus einer anderen Kette hier. Und, ja, der muss dann halt nach links oder rechts in ein anderes Band drüber verschoben werden, wenn er noch genügend Treibstoff dafür hat. Wenn er nicht genügend Treibstoff hat, dann musst du halt, ja, dir überlegen, welchen aus dem anderen Band du jetzt aufpasst, um ihn rüber zu schieben, damit in dem Band, wo du ihn hernimmst, ein Platz frei ist für den Spare, der nicht mehr so weit rüber kann. Also das ist ein unglaublich anspruchsvoller Job.
Hast du da Erkenntnisse, ob das auch schonmal so stattgefunden hat?
Das ist sogar, ja, ein gutes Dutzend, glaube ich, haben sie da ausgetauscht.
Ich wundere mich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen mit der Zahl. Du hast ja gesagt, es sind sechs Ringe. So, 66 Satelliten werden aktiv benutzt, also sind da 11 in jedem Band. Dann gibt es noch mal 11 Spare.
Sechs Spares, pro Band einer.
Also pro Band einer. Ah, okay, gut. Also das war dann die Zahl, die man da nicht braucht. Also sind es eigentlich 72.
Eigentlich 72, ja. Aber eigentlich sind es 66 Aktive. Lass mich mal die Bänder zählen. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Ja, 6 Bänder. 6 Bänder, 11 Satelliten plus 6 Spares. Operationell haben sie 72 gehabt. Das ist mal ein bisschen schwierig, weil die haben auch mehr hergestellt. Da standen dann am Boden welche. Es gibt eine Seite, auf der das Leben eines jeden Iridium-Satelliten gut dokumentiert ist. Da kann man sich das im Detail anschauen, was die einzelnen Satelliten jeweils so getrieben haben.
Das war auf jeden Fall schon kein einfaches Unterfangen. Hat aber funktioniert. Und verbessert sich das System dann auch über die Zeit? Wenn man immer mal wieder was Neues hochschicken muss, kann man ja im Prinzip immer wieder noch geilere Technik hochschicken. Und wenn man dann irgendwann mal alles komplett ersetzt hat, dann...
Das ist halt das Problem bei dieser Massenherstellung. Du hast keinen toll iterativen Prozess. Du kannst nicht einfach mal wieder hochschicken, schicken wir mal bessere drauf. Das geht da in Generationen. Und da ist Iridium gerade am Austauschen. Nämlich das alte System, was jetzt eben seit 20 Jahren da oben ist, ist langsam End of Life. Also die letzten Spares sind aufgebraucht. Mittlerweile hat sich die Erde auch ein bisschen weiter gedreht. Die Leute wollen Breitbanddaten haben. Zumindest die 2,4 Kilobit pro Sekunde. Die so einen Iridium-Sprachkanal hat, die man dann auch nur für Daten hat, sind nicht mehr zeitgemäß. Und ja, wird an der Zeit die komplette Konstellation auszutauschen. Da ist vor kurzem die erste Rakete mit den neuen Iridium-Satelliten gestartet. Das war eine Falcon 9 mit, sage und schreibe, zehn Satelliten an Bord. Zweimal fünf in so runden Dispensern. Wird es vom Launch auch ein schönes Video. Und ja, die sind mittlerweile in die Slots reingeswappt, wo sie die alten Satelliten ersetzen.
Zehn Satelliten in einem Start. Die müssen ja ganz schön eng zusammengefaltet werden. Oder sind die einfach so klein?
Die sind einfach so klein. Also die aktuellen Iridium-Satelliten, also die erste Generation, muss man sich vorstellen, ein bisschen größer als eine Telefonzelle, auch so vom Format her. Dreieckig allerdings und hat Antennen, die ein bisschen größer als so eine Türe sind. Auch von der Form her. Da hab ich noch gar nicht über Antennenformen gesprochen.
Nachlässig von uns. Die aktuelle Generation ist kleiner.
Die aktuelle Generation ist ein bisschen kleiner und hat vor allem eine andere Antennenform. Also wer noch Iridium-Flares sehen möchte, last chance to see, bevor die alten Iridium-Satelliten in die Orbitphase gehen, die neuen Antennen sind nicht mehr so schick. Also die aktuellen Iridium-Satelliten, die noch oben sind, die haben eben diese Türen großen Panel-Antennen. Das war auch die erste Verwendung, glaube ich, kommerziell von einem Antennen-Array. Da sind also ganz viele kleine Antennen drauf, ganz viele kleine, flache Antennen. Ein bisschen mehr als Zigaretten-Schachtel groß. Irgendwo so zwischen Zigaretten- und Schreihalschachtel-Größe. Und davon eben ganz viele auf einem silbernen Metallblech, was eben diese Sonne wunderschön spiegelt, weswegen wir die iridium flares sehen können. Damit projiziert der Satellit so ein Bienenwabenmuster auf die Erde runter, um mit den Telefonen zu sprechen. Das heißt, man hat nicht nur einen Spot, der von so einem Satelliten abgedeckt wird, sondern viele kleine Spots. Und das Telefon hand-overt nicht nur zwischen zwei Satelliten, also wenn es in einen Bereich von neun Satelliten kommt, sondern auch innerhalb des Satelliten. Also während der über einen hinweg fliegt, wechselt das Telefon von Antenne zu Antenne. Im Prinzip analog zu einem Mobilfunknetz, wo man auch an einer Basisstation mit einer Basisstation telefonieren kann. Aber wenn man um die Basisstation rumläuft, von einer auf die andere Antenne umgeschubst wird.
Das verstehe.
Das kommt also noch mal hinzu.
Also mit anderen Worten, Iridium hat dann ganz gut funktioniert, war zu teuer, ist dann quasi von der US Army rausgekauft worden. Deswegen lässt es sich auch weiterhin sinnvoll und auch profitabel betreiben. Und es wird auch weiter unterstützt. Und es wird auch so schnell nicht weggehen. Und es wird jetzt auch quasi in die zweite Generation überführt, die dann ein bisschen mehr Bandbreite verspricht.
Also statt 2K4 bis zu einem MBIT. Machen wir noch einen kleinen Einschub. Das gibt es auch jetzt schon mehr Bandbreite bei Iridium. Vorteil von dieser Polar-Orbit-Konstellation, also dass die Satelliten sich quasi am Nord- und Südpol treffen, da wo die Bänder zusammenlaufen.
Also in unterschiedlichen Höhen wahrscheinlich treffen.
In unterschiedlichen Höhen und ein bisschen auseinander, weil es sind nicht ganz 90 Grad, sondern eben, also wäre es 90 Grad, würden die tatsächlich einmal an den Polen vorbei. Wir sind auf ein bisschen beiseite, 86, 87,6 Grad. Hat den großen Vorteil, man hat an den Polen richtig doll gute Abdeckung. Und so Orte wie die Amundsen-Scott-Station am Südpol, am geografischen Südpol, ist sozusagen der Ort, wo man den besten Iridium-Empfang hat, also wo man sehr viele Satelliten gleichzeitig sehen kann. Deswegen, die schon sehr früh angefangen haben, da nicht nur ein Telefon hinzuparken, sondern gleich eine ganze Hand voll. Weil ist halt gerade mal völlig wurscht, wie viele Kanäle sie da... Das ist einer der Orte, wo sie wahrscheinlich neben ein paar Leuten, die da noch so rumlaufen, in einer Situation sitzen. Also da gibt es nicht so viele Menschen, die gerade Iridium telefonieren wollen. Da kann man dann auch so ein bisschen mehr als die 2,4. Ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen Breitband, weil das, was wir da haben, ist glaube ich mindestens 128 Kilobit. Aber da machen sie sozusagen Kanalbündelung.
Na okay, aber ich meine, das ist ja immer noch dadurch begrenzt, dass man im Prinzip eine Gesamtkapazität des Netzes hat von 10 Megabit.
Nicht von 10 Megabit, sondern die Gesamtkapazität zum Boden ist eingeschränkt durch W4, die Basisstation, also die Ground Station vermitteln kann. Zwischen den Satelliten hast du jeweils 10 Megabit. Das reicht um, muss man sich jetzt ausrechnen, wie viele Gespräche man darüber bekommt.
Können die machen, aber was können die Bodenstationen machen? Die machen nicht diese 10 Megabit.
Die können glaube ich 10.000 Gespräche parallel.
Was ist denn der Bedarf für einen normalen Gesprächskanal?
Ein normaler Gesprächskanal hat eben diese 2,4 Kilobit.
2,4 Kilobit.
Genau. Und jeder Satellit kann gleichzeitig 1100 dieser Kanäle leisten Richtung Erde runter.
Ja, was gibt es denn noch außer Iridium? Das ist doch jetzt nicht das einzige Netz, was wir da oben drauf finden.
Parallel zu Iridium hat sich mit ganz anderer Technologie auch ein System versucht, im Erddraht-Orbit zu etablieren. Bei Iridium haben wir die 2,4 Kilobit Kanäle, die in –doch nochmal ein bisschen technisch werden –in einem FDMA-TDMA-Verfahren verwendet werden. Im Prinzip dasselbe, was auch in Marsat gemacht hat. Du hast eine Frequenz und die Frequenz teilst du auf in unterschiedliche Zeitschlitze. Du sagst deinem Telefon, hier sende du zu der Zeit, sende du zu der Zeit und teilst sozusagen diese eine Frequenz in der Zeitebene auf.
Also FDMA ist die Frequenz Division Multiplexing.
Genau, weil du nicht nur eine dieser Frequenzen hast, die du aufteilst, sondern eine ganze Handvoll.
Und TMDA ist halt entsprechend Time Division. Also einmal durch die Frequenz geteilt, einmal durch die Zeit geteilt.
Genau, also die Telefone sind nicht die ganze Zeit und nicht auf einen Frequenz, sondern immer nur auf einer und nur alle in Intervallen.
Und alle teilen sich das sozusagen?
Und alle teilen sich das, genau. Das ist im Prinzip wie bei GSM. Da hast du auch unterschiedliche Frequenzen und die einzelnen Telefone teilen sich das auf. Jetzt gab es aber zu der Zeit nicht nur GSM, sondern in den USA auch CDMA. CDMA ist, da steckt Qualcomm relativ tief drin in der technologischen Entwicklung. Und da werden unterschiedliche Codes verwendet, um ein Signal zu übertragen. Ich hoffe, ich erzähl's keinen.
Das heißt ja dann auch Code-Multiplex-Verfahren. Genau, Code-Multiplex-Verfahren.
Da nimmst du deine Bits, spreizt sie, modulierst einen Code und sendest den. Und wenn das Signal der Code ist, dann ist es eine 1. Wenn das der inverse Code ist, ist es eine 2. Äh, eine 0.
Du erfindest gerade das Binaersystem neu.
Genau, das sind diese zwei Werte, die du eben mit einem Code überträgst. Und das ist ganz schön DSP-Voodoo. Also du brauchst da anspruchsvollere digitale Signalverarbeitung, weil wenn das alle machen, ihren Code da so senden, dann hast du halt einen Rauschen. Und du musst raus diesen Rauschen und zu Hilfe des Codes, kannst du wieder rausextrahlen, ob das jetzt eine 1 oder eine 0 war. Hat unglaublich viele Vorteile, wenn man das mal gemeistert hat, das zu können, weil Störungen nicht mehr so zum Tragen kommen. Wenn so ein Zeitschlitz gestört ist, dann hast du halt deinen Bit verloren oder deine Daten, die da drin sind. So ein CDMA-Signal ist weniger anfällig dafür. Eignet sich daher also auch im Prinzip prima für Satellitenkommunikation. Also Qualcomm hat gesagt, was ihre Motorola kann, können wir auch. Aber wir verzichten auf den Engineering-Aufwand mit den Inter-Satellite-Links. Wir brauchen keine Satelliten, die untereinander sprechen, weil wir schießen da jetzt weniger drauf und nutzen die im niedrigen Eartorbit, auch wie Inmarsat das macht, als reine Verstärker. Hat den Vorteil, wenn man ein Upgrade fahren möchte auf sein System, dann muss man die Satelliten nicht austauschen. Sondern dann kann man weiterhin die Satelliten nutzen, wie Inmarsat gemacht hat. Die haben ja da immer wieder neue Technologie auf Basis der alten deployed. Bei Inmarsat sogar später mit den Satelliten, die sie nicht mehr aktiv für ihre Telefonie genutzt haben, haben sie dann für irgendwelche anderen Dienste weiter vermietet, bis sie dann wirklich mal keinen Treibstoff mehr hatten und abgeschaltet wurden. Aber ja, also die haben dann ein Satellitennetz gebaut, was rein auf so verstärkere Satelliten funktioniert hat. Auch in der anderen Konstellation, die haben sich nicht für eine polare Konstellation entschieden, was nahe liegt, weil wenn du nur das Signal weiter schickst, dann muss irgendwo in der Nähe auch eine Gateway sein, also eine Satellitengrundstation, weil die Sichtverbindung, Satellitengrundstation, Satellit und Telefon muss gegeben sein. Das kannst du an den Polkappen nicht so sicher stellen, da wäre der Aufwand, überall in so hohe Stationen hinzustellen, für die wenigen Teilnehmer, die du da hast, nicht vertretbar. Und haben sich dann dafür eine Walker-Konstellation entschieden, die die Polkappen ausspart.
Und wie heißt das Netz?
GlobalStar.
Das GlobalStar nimmt auch eine Technologie, das CDMA, was in dem Mobilfunkbereich vertreten ist, lässt aber den ganzen Fancy-Schmenzy, wir haben hier so untereinander kommunizierende Satellitenobjekte, Netzkram einfach weg, basiert eigentlich mehr auf dem einfachen Ansatz von Inmarsat, aber halt mit höheren Kapazitäten und mit besserer Digitalübertragung.
Ja, höhere Kapazitäten insofern, als dass so ein Satellit auch wieder seine Spotbeams hat. Kann man sich bei Globestar vorstellen wie so ein Gänseblümchen, das in der Mitte einen und außenrum, ich glaube, 15 weitere Beams. Und sie haben zwei unterschiedliche, in zwei unterschiedlichen Frequenzbereichen. Bei Inmarsat hat das hier die 1,6 oder 1,5. Die hast du auch bei Globestar, aber sie haben auch 2,5 Gigahertz. Das heißt, sie haben parallel zwei Frequenzbänder zur Verfügung, um Kommunikation zu betreiben. Einmal für Simplex-Kommunikation. Das heißt, du hast ein Endgerät, was eine Nachricht schickt. Das ist bei 1,6 Gigahertz. Und die Satelliten reichen das zur Bundestation weiter und da wird die Nachricht dann verarbeitet. Und du hast die 2,5, um Telefonie zu betreiben. Höhere Frequenz, bessere Bandbreite, weil du mehr Daten unterbringst in deinem Signal. Deswegen ist die Gesprächsqualität bei Globistar, auch weil sie einen anderen Codec verwendet haben. Iridium verwendet den AMBE-Codec. Wer sich das nochmal vertiefend angucken möchte, ist Globistar, den Self-Codec mit ein bisschen höherer Bitrate. Nämlich 4,8 Kilobit bei Globistar und 2,4 Kilobit bei Iridium. Das heißt, die Gesprächsqualität ist deutlich besser. Und da ich das auch nur so verstärkende Satelliten sind und da kein Processing stattfindet auf dem Satelliten selber, ist auch die Latenz noch mal in einem Mühe besser. Ist auf jeden Fall angenehmer. Wir haben jetzt natürlich das Problem, dass sie auch viele Ground Stations brauchen.
Was verwendest du denn eigentlich?
Das kommt immer drauf an. Also das, was ich lange Jahre echt sehr gerne verwendet habe, ist ein Iridium-Pager, weil das ein System war, wo du global in eine Richtung erreichbar bist, ohne dem System mitteilen zu müssen, wo du genau bist. Also ich konnte den Pager einbuchen auf, ich bin jetzt in West- oder Osteuropa. Dann haben sie über die Iridium-Satelliten in West- oder Osteuropa meine Pager-Nachrichten verschickt. Wenn ich da gerade unterwegs war und der Pager in Fensternähe stand, dann hat er die bekommen. Und die Iridium-Pager, wie würdest du das von der Größe beschreiben? Ich reichte mal hinüber.
Na ja, eine kleinere Zigaretten-Schachtel, bisschen quadratischer geformt.
Quadratisch, weil hinten im Pager verbaut eine kleine Panel-Antenne drin ist, die genau abgestimmt ist auf 1,62 Gigahertz.
Der Pager, also der empfängt nur.
Das ist wie in den 90ern. Du rufst eine unglaublich teure Nummer an, hinterlässt eine Nachricht und dann klingelt es bei mir.
Und dann wird die aber sozusagen von einem Satelliten über einen längeren Zeitraum, über einen größeren Bereich ausgesendet.
Ich buche mich halt über deren Internetseite mittlerweile. Früher hat man das bei Telefon gemacht. Da gab es dann auch das Follow-Me-Paging. Das heißt, wenn du einen iridium-satelliten Telefon und einen Pager hattest, dann hat sich der Pager immer da eingebucht, wo gerade dein Telefon sich zuletzt eingebucht hat, weil die wissen natürlich, wo das Telefon zu Hause ist. Und können dir dann den Pager entsprechend nachführen. Das kann man auch über das Internet jetzt machen, sagen ich bin in der und der Message Delivery Area nennt sich das. Und dann wird in dem Teil der Erde deine Nachricht ausgesendet. Schicken kann man die per E-Mail oder über messaging.diridium.com Hast du dann so ein Feld, wo du die Nummer eintippen kannst und Nachricht und dann kriegst du die zugeschickt.
Was für Nachrichten hast du dir dann so zuschicken lassen?
Monitoring zum Beispiel. Wenn man Server hat, ob die Server noch laufen.
Du wolltest sozusagen die Freiheit haben, in die totale Pampa zu ziehen.
Genau, richtig. Und nicht mit Leuten sprechen zu müssen. Wenn irgendwas ist, dann soll mein Computer Bescheid sagen, aber ich will mit keinen Menschen sprechen. Wenn jemand was für mich möchte und meine Nummer freundlicherweise bekommen hat, dann kann er mir auch schreiben. Aber ich will mit niemandem telefonieren. Genau, hat natürlich den Vorteil, du kannst auch im Flieger die Nachrichten empfangen. Also du weißt, wenn du aussteigst, musst du als allererstes mal telefonieren oder deinen Laptop aufklappen und dich um einen Server kümmern.
Das heißt, Flugzeuge, da geht immer die Satellitentelefonie immer durch?
Ich glaube, sie sehen es echt ungern, wenn man an Bord mit einem Satellitentelefon anfängt zu telefonieren, weil das so ein bisschen, ja, aber zumindest Pager-Nachrichten empfangen im Flieger war drin.
Wow, aber du hast schon mal telefoniert im Flugzeug.
Ja, aber nur mit einem Telefon war es im Flugzeug. Das war dann immer satt. Also man hat ja öfter mal im Flieger, in Flight Entertainment, so ein Hand-Dings, was auch so einen Kreditkartenschlitz hat, wo man seine Kreditkarte durchziehen kann. Und ein Telefonat später, ja, ist man den Preis eines gehobenen Abendessens los, hat aber dann Satelliten telefoniert. Also das gibt es seit Ende 90er.
Aber es würde schon funktionieren.
Es würde wahrscheinlich funktionieren, ja.
Du hast das noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich hab das noch nicht ausprobiert, nee.
Überrascht mich sehr. Auch nicht im Klo?
Auch nicht im Klo, nee. Also ich hab tatsächlich einmal mit einem Satellitentelefon im Flieger oder vor dem Flieger Probleme bekommen. Das war von Südafrika zurück. Und in Fliegern ist ja grundsätzlich Funkgeräte nicht erlaubt. So finden die ganz doll unlustig, wenn da Leute mit Funkgeräten unterwegs sind, weil Flugfunk und so weiter. Ich hatte also mein Iridium-Phone, wie ich es damals immer hatte, in meinem Handgepäck, weil wenn der Flieger dann doch mal runtergeht, dass man der hält, der ein Telefon dabei hat, dann sagt du, ich, Herr Flieger kaputt, abholen Taxi. Also ein Satellitentelefon, Handgepäck, total praktisch. Fand der südafrikanische Border-Mensch überhaupt gar nicht und gab mir zu verstehen, no walkie-talkie, laut und plain. Es hat mich eine halbe Stunde und die zu Hilfenahme des Vorgesetzten sein, des Vorgesetzten genommen, um zur Lösung zu kommen, ok, wenn wir aus diesem Ding, was ich für ein Telefon halte, eher für einen walkie-talkie, hin die Batterie rausnimmt, das ist kein Gerät mehr. Das hat dann funktioniert, ja.
Oh Mann.
Drum ist mein, also ich hab das dann an Bord lieber sein lassen. Die Leute gucken ja eh immer schon, wenn man sein Smartphone mit GPS offen hat und eine App, die einem Cockpit, so virtueller Horizont und so weiter anzeigt, Geschwindigkeit und alles. Da gab es auf dem, das war... Prima GPS-Empfang. Und gibt halt auch...
Aber man braucht noch Internet dazu? Ach so, mit lokal gecashten Karten meinst du?
Nicht mit Karten, sondern einfach so diese Cockpit-Dinge, die man da so sieht, dieser künstliche Horizont, der oben braun, unten blau ist und sich, wenn das Flugzeug neigt, mit dem Flugzeug neigt. Und ja, so zeigs.
Ja, man kann mit solchen Sachen Leute wirklich sehr nervös machen, das kann ich mir ganz gut vorstellen. Jetzt hatten wir bisher Inmarsat und wir hatten Global Star.
Genau, wir waren bei den Global Star Gateways stehen geblieben. Die wurden betrieben von, die haben sich da so ein bisschen ein anderes Modell zurecht gelegt, auch mit Roaming-Partnern und so weiter. Die wurden betrieben von ganz unterschiedlichen Firmen weltweit. Also im Gegensatz zu der Motorola-Nummer mit Iridium, wurden die Global Star Gateways in den jeweiligen Regionen von den jeweiligen Tecos. In Europa war das in Italien ElsaCom und Spanien war nochmal ein anderer Betreiber. In der Türkei steht auch immer noch ein Gateway, der Stand von Global Star Eurasia und dann ihre eigenen Regionalgesellschaften auch im koreanisch-japanischen Raum da kommen. Also wer so einen Gateway haben wollte, konnte sich da quasi eins hinstellen. Die Karte ist auf Wikipedia verlinkt, verlinken wir auch noch und schauen uns. Die ist relativ bunt mit ganz vielen unterschiedlichen Gateways. Die unterschiedliche Teile der Welt abdecken. Wenn man auf die Karte schaut, sieht man halt, dass das wirklich immer nur bis, ja, welche ist das, von der Küste ein bisschen raus, aber halt keine flächendeckende Abdeckung ist, weil eben die Gespräche immer zum lokalen Gateway gehen, was gleichzeitig das Telefon und den Satelliten sehen muss.
Was sind denn jetzt noch für weitere Netze am Start? Sind das im Wesentlichen so die großen und wichtigen oder?
Das sind im Wesentlich die großen und wichtigen, wobei Globestar so eine Wichtigkeit verloren oder sie nie bekommen hat, weil das ist ganz tragisch. Die haben sich für einen bisschen höheren Orbit entschieden und gesagt, wir sind auch mit 1400 Kilometern mit unserem CDMA noch gut dabei und brauchen dann dafür weniger Satelliten, 32 oder gar noch weniger, 24, dann mit der zweiten Konstellation, also der Austausch der Satelliten. Sie sagten, ja, fliegen wir auf 1400 Kilometer. Durften dann Bekanntschaften machen mit der südamerikanischen Anomalie. Um die Erde herum gibt es Strahlungsgürtel, ein Allenbeet. Und in der Höhe von Südamerika tischt dieser Strahlungsgürtel so ein bisschen tiefer rein. Das ist eine Anomalie in dem Strahlungsgürtel, wo...
Was meinst du genau mit Strahlungsgürtel? Also reden wir jetzt vom Magnetfeld der Erde und dem Abweichen der Strahlen.
Du machst doch so Space-Dings. Erklär du doch mal den Van Allen-Bild. Ich kann das nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich da so viel darüber weiß, um ehrlich zu sein.
Vielleicht kriegen wir es zusammen gepostet. Also die Erde hat ein Magnetfeld. Und das Magnetfeld sorgt dafür, dass Strahlung, das heißt von der Sonne, ne, hauptsächlich von der Sonne, von der Sonne ja, abgelenkt wird und nicht direkt auf die Erde trifft. In dem Strahlungsfeld hat es allerdings Zonen mit erhöhter Strahlung. Das ist der Van Allen Radiation Belt. Wenn man jetzt Satelliten betreibt, dann möchte man ja, dass die möglichst lange leben und nicht von so Strahlungsteilchen getroffen werden, die dann zur Folge haben, dass da im Falle der Iridium-Satelliten werden es die Motorola-Prozessoren wahrscheinlich, die da am anfälligsten sind. Wenn da so ein Teilchen durchkacheln, dann kann es halt sein, dass der kaputt ist. Und um das zu vermeiden, fliegt man die Satelliten halt in Orbits, die möglichst strahlungsarm sind, aber eben die Missionen, die sie haben, trotzdem noch erfüllen können.
Aber so ab 700 Kilometern Höhe geht das dann halt schon so langsam los. Und jetzt hat sich Globalstar quasi mit seiner gewählten Position so mitten in den Bereich reingesetzt, wo es dann schon etwas energetischer geht.
Genau. Und das hatte zur Folge, dass eben gesagt, da sind zwei Sorten von Transpondern an Bord. Einmal S-Band-Transponder bei 2,5 Gigahertz und einmal L-Band-Transponder in 1,6 Gigahertz. Die L-Band-Transponder, 1,6 Gigahertz, waren für Nachrichtenzustellung und die S-Band, 2,5, für Duplex Sprache, Sprachübertragung in zwei Richtungen. Telefonie nennt man das, glaube ich. Die waren so ein bisschen anfällig für diese Strahlung. Die sind ihnen dann so ein bisschen kaputtgegangen. Weswegen das System eben nicht mehr zu 100 Prozent der Zeit zur Verfügung stand, sondern wenn da so ein Satellit vorbeigekommen ist, mit einem kaputten S-Bahn-Transponder, war halt Schluss mit Telefonieren. Hat Lowstar dann, die sind dann pleite gegangen.
Deswegen?
Deswegen. Also mussten sie zumindest Chapter 11 anmelden.
Konkurs.
Konkurs. Und haben gesagt, ja, alles gut, alles gut, alles gut. Wir haben da so ein Tool auf unserer Seite, Optimum Availability Tool. Da gibt es da einen, wo du gerade bist, und dann sagen wir dir, wann du telefonieren kannst. Und außerdem, außerdem, erst first in der Geschichte der Satellitentelefonie, wer bietet eine Telefonie-Flatrate? Also, wenn du dann mal telefonieren kannst, dann ist dann das Flat. Da hast du, glaub ich, 40 Euro pro Monat und hast dann eine Telefonie-Flatrate. Also wenn es halt funktioniert, gerade wenn die Konstellation günstig steht.
Und nicht so viele Leute gleichzeitig ihre Flatrate nutzen wollen, dass die Bänder dann auch voll sind.
Ja. Zur selben Zeit haben sie dann auch überlegt, was können wir mit unseren Simplex-Transceivers machen? Also dahingehend war das für Glowstar ein Segen, möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen. Aber ob sie auf die Idee auch sonst gekommen wären, man weiß es nicht. Und haben ein Produkt, das nennt sich Spot Messenger. Das ist so ein orangenes Gerät, ein bisschen größer als der Region Pager. Also von der Größe her weiß ich es nicht. Also so ein kleines Satellitentaschenradio. Und mit dem, das konnte man dazu nutzen, oder kann man dazu nutzen, über die Satelliten Nachrichten zu verschicken. Zielgruppe sind Leute auf Expeditionen, die einfach mit den drei Knöpfen, die da drauf sind, ihren Lieben zu Hause sagen können, hier ist meine aktuelle GPS-Position, mir geht es gut, ich bin noch in keine Gletscherspalte gerutscht. Oder den anderen Knopf für, mir geht es nicht gut, ich bin gerade hier und bin in einer Gletscherspalte mit Satellitentemfang. Was natürlich nicht mehr erforderlich ist.
Das kann man nicht haben, aber es ist gut, wenn man sie senden kann, wenn sie gebraucht wird.
Genau, und es hat auch nicht 100% Satellitentemfang benötigt. Sondern du guckst auf die Taste und irgendwann wird schon das Ding mal mit dem Satelliten gesprochen haben. Also du musst nicht sofort eine Antwort haben, weil du kannst auch keine Antwort empfangen. Das ist halt ein Einweg-Kommunikationsgerät. Und die haben sie für relativ günstig, glaube 100, 200 Euro mit einer Handvoll Nachrichten pro Monat für so 10, 20 Euro im Monat. Und das hat sich wohl ganz gut verkauft. Und vor allem mit den Satelliten in dem Zustand, wie sie halt waren, noch prima abbildbar, weil es einfach die anderen Transponder, die nicht in Mitleidenschaft gezogen wurden.
Aber Global Star ist eigentlich so ein bisschen on its way out. Also es ist so ein Netzwerk, was man jetzt so nicht weiter betreiben will.
Ich würde es den Underdog nennen, weil sie haben es trotzdem immer geschafft, ihren Dienst weiter zu betreiben. Sie haben auch in den letzten Jahren wieder eine Konstellation, nicht mit 32, sondern mit 24 Satelliten gelauncht. Im Prinzip selbe Technik. Vielleicht ein bisschen besserer Rauschabstand, aktueller Transceiver, aktueller Equipment, mit dem dann noch mal ein bisschen mehr rauszuholen ist aus diesen Kanälen. Aber die gibt es weiterhin.
Das heißt, nur die Gateways nicht mehr.
Also Gateways wurden einige abgeschaltet. Da wird jetzt auch mehr durch Globistar direkt betrieben. Globistar USA, Globistar Europe und ich glaube in Asien.
Aber dieses Problem mit dem Gürtel, mit dem Strahlungsgürtel, das kriegen die nicht so richtig weg.
Naja, musste halt Franziva nehmen, die da ein bisschen strahlungsresistenter sind. Das haben sie vielleicht einfach falsch eingeschätzt.
Na ist das noch fixbar?
Nee, die, die kaputt sind, die sind halt kaputt.
Ja gut, aber sie können ja jetzt neue hochschicken.
Genau. Gibt es auch im Internet, wenn einen das interessiert, wie die Konstellationen von Lobestar sich so über die letzten Jahre, bei der FCC, der Regulierungsbehörde in den USA für Telekommunikation und Funk-Dinge, da reichen die immer mal wieder Notices ein, dass sie an ihrer Konstellation Dinge verändern. Da steht dann relativ detailliert drin, wir hatten vorher eine 32-Satelliten-Walker-Konstellation, wir bauen die jetzt um zu einer 24-Satelliten-Walker-Konstellation, nutzen die alten Satelliten noch für das L-Band, die neuen Satelliten hauptsächlich für das S-Band. Da ist schon Bewegung drin. Und im Gegensatz zu Iridium haben sie halt den unglaublichen Vorteil beim Spielen mit ihrer Konstellation, dass sie nicht diese präzise Slot-Aufteilung brauchen, weil sie halt keine Inter-Satellite-Links haben. Also sie können da einfach mal so ein paar Satelliten in anderen Bahnen fliegen lassen, um für den Simplex-Dienst eine Abdeckung zu haben, wo in 80 Prozent der Zeiten ein Satellit zu sehen ist und in 20 Prozent halt nicht. Und für ihre Telefonie dann die anderen, neueren Satelliten auf einer ein bisschen anderen Umlaufbahn. Die machen also ein bisschen Mix and Match mit den alten und neuen Satelliten.
Also manche werden schon noch ein bisschen durchhalten.
Die werden auf jeden Fall durchhalten, ja. Scheint Wille und Finanzierung dahinter zu sein.
Und sie waren auch relativ kreativ, um sich da sozusagen neue Anwendungen einfallen zu lassen, die die Leute vielleicht auch wirklich gebraucht haben. Die es jetzt bei Iridium nicht gibt. Wobei Iridium könnte das doch auch machen mit Notfalltasten, oder?
Iridium hat, nachdem Globostars mit diesen Taschen-Messengern angefangen hat, tatsächlich auch so ein Produkt rausgebracht, auf Basis ihres Dienstes Short Burst Data SPD, was neben der Telefonie und dem Paging ein weiterer Dienst ist, den das Iridium Netz hat. Das ist so wie SMS, nur, ja, so wie SMS. Sprich, du hast da ein Gerät, was zum Beispiel an einem Container, an einem Schiffscontainer oder so dranhängt. Das kann Nachrichten mit Positionen oder so los schicken. Das gibt es dann natürlich auch in klein für Expeditionen. Hat den Vorteil, dass man dann da auch Nachrichten mit verschicken kann. Also das ist nicht nur so ein Ja-Nein-Danke, sondern kannst das auch zum Twittern verwenden zum Beispiel.
Darauf haben wir gewartet. Wo kommt denn dieses Iridium-Messaging zum Einsatz? Also was sind denn da so die Anwendungen?
Na zum einen im kleinen Terminals, mit dem man von unterwegs Twittern kann oder Nachrichten verschicken, einzeln oder Nachrichten empfangen. Das ist so ein bisschen das Nachfolgeprodukt für den Pager, um auch in die Gegenrichtung, also nicht nur Nachrichten empfangen zu können, sondern auch Nachrichten verschicken zu können. Die Module sind relativ klein, brauchen wenig Strom und werden deswegen auch gerne an Schiffscontainern verbaut oder in Flugzeuge eingesetzt oder überall, wo man eben so einen Kurz-Nachrichten-Austausch haben möchte.
Das heißt, es sind so quasi so Tracking-Module, die man einfach irgendwo ranbappt?
Genau, muss halt immer Antenne Richtung freier Himmel haben, aber nicht besonders ausgerichtet werden. Und dann kann man da Nachrichten hin und her schicken.
Das heißt, das kann man nicht einfach in seinen Container reinlegen, sondern das muss dann schon am Schiff irgendwie explizit angebracht werden?
Genau, richtig, ja.
Und wer macht das?
Naja, jeder, der irgendwas tracken möchte.
Na gut, aber ich meine, man weiß ja eh, wo das Schiff ist.
Ja, aber du weißt nicht, wo dein Container ist. Der wird vielleicht mal auf dem LKW verladen. Also das ist ja intermodal in Transport mit so einem Container. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie eine Spedition bist, wie nachher...
Ja, aber kann man den so an den Container anbringen, dass er beim Verladen dann keinen Schaden nimmt?
Ich gehe von aus. Also zumindest wird es dafür auch verwendet. Oder halt für, ja, wenn du eine LKW-Flotte oder so hast, dann kommt da so ein kleines SBDE-Terminal rein.
Okay, also es gibt da irgendwo eine Ecke, wo man das so gefahrlos oder halbwegs gefahrlos anbringen kann. Weil ich denk mir, wenn die da alle aufeinander gestapelt und aneinander gestoßen werden, dann könnte es ein bisschen eng werden.
Ist aber nicht der einzige Dienst. Also es gibt auch andere Satellitendienste, die spezifisch dieses Messaging, sich dieses Messaging verschrieben haben. Und in dem Moment, wo du nur Nachrichten austauschst und nicht darauf angewiesen bist, auch mal eine bidirektionale Echtzeitverbindung zu haben für Telefonie oder Datenvertragung, kannst du ganz anders designen, kannst du ganz anders planen. Du brauchst keine Konstellation mehr, die 100 Prozent immer die Erde abdeckt und Dinge, Gespräche oder Kanäle zuweist und Daten hin und her transportiert. Sondern dann reicht es dir eigentlich, wenn innerhalb eines bestimmten Zeitfensters mal ein Satellit zu sehen ist und du einen Datenaustausch machen kannst. Du hast dann auch nicht die großen Datenmengen, sondern das kleinere Datenpaket. Du musst nicht irgendwo bei 1,6 Gigahertz unterwegs sein, sondern das reichen vielleicht auch 150 Megahertz, was wiederum den Vorteil hat, dass sich das Signal besser ausbreitet und dass du nicht unbedingt eine direkte Sichtverbindung brauchst. Und da sind wir dann bei so Nischen-Systemen wie Orbcom. Das sind weitere Satellitensysteme, was im niedrigen Erdrobot unterwegs ist, irgendwo zwischen Iridium und Globistar und aus relativ einfachen kleinen Satelliten besteht. Die sehen so aus wie so eine Filmdose, nicht für Foto, sondern für Kinofilm, so eine alte runde Schachtel. Was daher kommt, das ist wirklich ein Low-Budget-Projekt. Die wollten möglichst viele Satelliten mit einem Raketenstart raufbekommen. Und so eine Rakete ist rund. Die hat oben so eine Kammer, in der die Satelliten drin sind. Bei den aktuellen Iridium-Starts waren das zwei Rondelle, wo jeweils fünf Satelliten drinnen sind, übereinander gestapelt. Da sieht man auch schön, dass die Satelliten trapezförmig sind, um in dieses Rondell möglichst viel Technik unterbringen zu können. Und bei Orbcom hat man sich gesagt, die stellen wir dann nicht hochkant rein, sondern eben flach als Dosen. Das ist so ein Stapel runder Scheiben, die oben in dieser Raketenkapsel drin sind, die dann eine nach der anderen in den Orbit gesetzt werden, sich ausfalten. Dann hast du in der Mitte diese Filmdose und zu den Seiten weg noch mal so kreisrunde Solar-Panels. Und nach unten zeigt eine Antenne, die auch nicht mehr so aufwendig wie Iridium mit den Antennengrids, die Tür groß sind, sondern das ist einfach so eine spiralförmige, lange Antenne, die auf 150 MHz.
Ich sehe gerade, die ersten haben sie wohl tatsächlich mit diesen Pegasus-Raketen, die von Flugzeugen aus gestartet werden, hochgebracht. Und zuletzt hat man das ja gehört, weil SpaceX das mit der Falcon 9 gestartet hat. Also das war, glaube ich, sogar die Mission, wo sie dann das erste Mal wieder richtig gelandet sind mit ihrer Rakete.
Auf dem Westland.
Ja, anderes Thema. Okay, das heißt, die Sache wird auch flexibler und es geht eigentlich auch immer ein bisschen mehr hin in allgemeine Datenanwendung und weniger dieses tatsächliche Telefonieren. Weil ich so das Gefühl hab, so Telefonieren ist durch Iridium eigentlich wunderbar abgedeckt. Und die anderen können sich jetzt sozusagen auf andere Sachen konzentrieren, wo die Anforderungen nicht so hoch sind, wie man sie eben für Telefonie braucht. Aber dafür sehr viel flexibler ist bei Datenanwendung.
Ja, nicht nur die Anforderungen, sondern man guckt sich halt an, was für eine technische Plattform man hat und was kann man, was die anderen nicht können. Also was Iridium jetzt nicht direkt kann, ist breitbandige Daten zur Verfügung stellen. Die haben da zwar ein Produkt, aber das ist mit ganz viel Gaffa und Heißkleber zusammen geschustert. Ich hab mir das mal angucken können. Es gibt davon nicht so doll viele, so angucken mit Aufschrauben. Das ist so ein kleines, flaches Radom mit mehreren Satelliten-Modems drin und mehreren Antennen rund um dieses Radom und auf diesem Radom und einem Signalprozessor, der zwischen den Antennen hin und her schaltet. Also den Aufwand, den Iridium betreiben muss, um breitbandig Daten zu kriegen, der ist nicht zu knapp, weil sie dann halt Kanalbindelungen und so weiter fahren müssen. Drum hat sich Intel-SAT, Quatsch, nicht Intel-SAT, INMAR-SAT dann gesagt, ja, das, was die Iridium-Leute da mit den Spotbeams machen können, das ist vorher die tolle Technologie. Das können wir doch auch im geostationären Orbit. Wir haben dann halt ein bisschen größere Spotbeams oder vielleicht ein paar mehr, aber die bewegen sich dafür nicht. Warum man da Spotbeams verwendet? Also statt einem globalen Beam und einem Frequenzbereich, den man dann auf einem Drittel oder Viertel des Erdbeers verwendet, hast du viele kleinere, ausgeleuchtete Bereiche.
In welche Bereiche leuchtet man dann aus? Immer noch alles, aber halt separat?
Immer noch alles, aber halt separat. Weil auch die Technik, Iridium war da Vorreiter mit dem Antennen-Array, wo du halt viele Antennen zusammenschaltest und dann Beamforming machen kannst, nennt sich das. Also du, durch die Überlagerung von einem Signal in mehrere Antennen, kannst du mit den Antennen zielen. Und wenn du ein bisschen mehr Platz hast in deinem Satelliten, dann kannst du da richtig schicke Technik verbauen. Die ersten allerdings, die damit angefangen haben, war nicht Inmarsat, sondern Thrya. Das ist ein arabisches Konsortium. Die haben den ersten Satelliten heraufgeschossen, der quasi auf einer GSM-ähnlichen Technik, nennt sich GMR1, Satellitentelefoniedienste zunächst an Feil geboten hat. Das war von daher ein sehr abenteuerliches und wieder Pionierunterfangen, als dass sie da einen riesengroßen Reflektor ausgefeitet haben im Weltraum. Das ist eine Carbonfaserkonstruktion mit einer Folie, die am Boden sozusagen zusammengepackt, eng in diesem Satelliten drin ist. Da muss irgendwie auch rausgeschossen werden. Und wurde dann im Weltraum ausgefeitet zu einem großen Spiegel.
Und also der Spiegel dann was? Also ist das im Prinzip jetzt wieder der gleiche Ansatz wie bei Global Star, dass man einfach nur wieder runter sendet, was hochgesendet wurde oder?
Nee, die hatten da eben tatsächlich sowas wie eine Mobilfunkbasis-Station im Satelliten. Also bei GSM-Netzen hat man ja mehrere Komponenten, die miteinander sprechen, um einem den Mobilfunkempfang möglich zu machen. Zum einen die Basis-Station, das Ding, wo die Antennen dranhängen, mit dem das Telefon direkten Funkkontakt aufnimmt, den Base-Station-Controller, das Ding, was im Prinzip der Basis-Station vorgibt hier deine Frequenzen und das ganze Handling der Kanäle vornimmt. Und im Prinzip diese zwei Komponenten hatten sie im Weltraum. Sie haben also diese 12 x 16 Meter Reflektorspiegel ausgefaltet, was sie übrigens nur im Weltraum machen können. Der ist so leicht und dünn gebaut, dass man ihn auf der Erde ohne Tragkonstruktion gar nicht ausfalten könnte. Der würde an der Gravitation brechen. Also ja, diesen großen Spiegel ausgefaltet. Und der zielt jetzt nicht nur auf die Erde, sondern eben Satelliten auf so eine Array-Antenne, also das ist ein Raster aus kleinen Antennen, die ihr Signal über diesen 12 x 16 Meter Spiegel auf die Erde projizieren. Was also auf der Erde dann wie in einem Mobilfunknetz auch unterschiedliche Zellen.
Das heißt, man hat quasi nicht eine Antenne, sondern man hat ganz viele kleine, die dann über diesen Spiegel sich quasi an verschiedensten Stellen auf der Erde abbilden.
Genau. Und das macht man im Mobilfunknetz so, dass man eben diese Zellen hat, um die Last besser verteilen zu können. Das heißt, du kannst einen und denselben Frequenzbereich mehrfach nutzen.
Wie groß sind diese Zellen dann auf der Erde?
Das kommt wieder darauf an, wo auf der Erde du bist, weil die Projektion von diesem Spiegel natürlich verzerrt wird durch die Erdoberfläche. Das heißt, Mittelmeer, Afrika hast du relativ engen Zellabstand. In Deutschland kannst du, glaube ich, es ist vorgesehen, dass du zwei Zellen empfangen kannst. Du empfängst natürlich mehr mit einer guten Antenne.
Aber jetzt reden wir wieder von geostationären Systemen.
Wir reden von geostationären.
Also Turaya jetzt anders als diese OrbCom-Geschichte und anders als Iridium, aber ebenso wie Global Star befindet sich im geostationären Orbit. Aber da teilen die quasi ihre eigene eine Position in viele separate Abdeckungsgebiete auf. Also nur, um ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wenn du es nicht genau weißt, wie groß ist dann so eine Zelle auf Äquator-Ebene?
Ich hätt's gesagt, um die 100 Kilometer, 50 bis 100 Kilometer.
Okay. Und dann, umso weiter man nach Norden oder Süden geht, wird es dann auch entsprechend verzerrt und größer.
Also es decken zwei Zellen, zumindest in denen so richtig erfährt man das ja nicht. Also da muss man dann schon selber dem Turayasatelliten zuhören, wo so seine Zellen sind, was man durchaus mit einem Genuradio, also mit einem oder mit einem SDR machen kann. Da gibt es auch dokumentiert im Internet Software für. Ja, lange redet gar keinen Sinn. In Deutschland sieht man oder sind vorgesehen zwei. Und die decken aber gleichzeitig auch die Niederlande und Großbritannien mit ab.
Aber ist immerhin schon mal eine Aufteilung?
Ist eine Aufteilung, genau. Und dadurch, dass man eben die Erde so ein bisschen aufteilt, kannst du halt einen und denselben Frequenzbereich mehrfach benutzen. Weil das ist das Teure an Satellitenkommunikation, ist einfach die Bandbreite. Wenn du jetzt so einen Megabit haben möchtest, auf einem geostationären Satelliten und das nur für dich alleine, dann bist du damit 5000 Euro im Monat bei. Und Satellitentelefonie teilt im Prinzip diese Bandbreite, die da ist, in kleinere Zeitbereiche ab. Da kannst du halt telefonieren. Und für die Zeit gehört dir diese Frequenz, dieser Zeitschlitz. Wenn du dieselbe Frequenz zweimal, dreimal nutzen und verkaufen kannst, wird natürlich die Minute günstiger. Und weitere Einsparungen, die Threyer an der Stelle hatte, war, dass sie eben das GmR1-System verwendet haben, was eben eine GSM-Adaption, Satelliten-Adaption vom GSM-Standard ist. Da hattest du, glaube ich, Harald hier schon mal.
Ja.
Der das mit dem GSM erklärt hat. Und für den GmR-Standard wurden halt bestimmte Dinge angepasst. Und da kannst du einfach ein Telefon, ein spezielles, ein Threyer-Telefon mit einer SIM-Karte verwenden. Die haben auch funktionierendes Roaming. Kann man sich also auch mit einer, ich glaube, auch Tools das in Deutschland, die mit den Roaming-Abkommen haben, einfach so Threyer-Telefon, SIM-Karte einlegen, bloß telefonieren. Und auch so Dienste wie SMS und ja.
Was kriegt man dann so an Daten daraus?
Genau, später dann auch eben GMPRS, so Satelliten-GPRS. Da kriegt man so um die 60 Kilobit mit einem Telefon. Also Telefon. Das musst du ungefähr in Richtung des Satelliten halten. Dadurch, dass das so ein Riesenreflektor hat, brauchst du nicht genau zielen, sondern das ist so leistungsstark in der Verstärkung, dass so Pi mal Daumen in die Richtung plus minus 30 Grad kannst du telefonieren. Wenn du komplett in Feuerfläche stehst, dann...
Wie groß muss man sich diesen Spiegel vorstellen, den das Ding ausfällt?
12 mal 16 Meter.
Das hat Inmarsat dann auch gemacht. Und die haben dann neben dem auch einem GMR 2, war das dann...
Die haben was gemacht? Die haben das mit dem Spiegel gemacht?
Die haben das mit dem Spiegel gemacht.
Also mit den neuen Satelliten, die sie nachgeliefert haben.
Inmarsat schießt so alle, jetzt muss ich lügen, 5 bis 7, 10 Jahre, was halt so eine Lebenszeit von den Satelliten ist. Oder die nützliche Lebenszeit, danach werden die natürlich immer noch so lange verwendet, bis Sprit alle ist. Aber so die nützliche Lebenszeit von der Technologie in allem, so 5 bis 7 Jahre, hatten sie also ihre vierte Generation aufgeschossen und auch diese Spiegel ausgefeitet. Darüber allerdings nicht nur Telefonie gemacht und so ein bisschen Daten, sondern wirklich auch das erste Mal richtig breitbandt. Das war dann Bigon, haben sie das genannt, Broadband Global Area Network.
Globaler geht es kaum.
Globaler geht es nicht. Local Area Network, LAN, Personal Area Network, die Bluetooth-Geräte am Körper und das Global Area Network.
Schick dir mal die Datei über meinen Garen.
Ja, und haben dann auch Geräte rausgebracht, die nicht größer als ein Laptop sind. Man muss sich so vorstellen, die nach 5 Seiten dafür aber 5 cm dick. Kannste hinstellen, fällt. Das ist zumindest das Gerät, das ich habe, einen Explorer. Früher hieß die anders, Neera, irgendwas 1010. Jedenfalls ist das ein Gerät, hat dann Akku, hat einen eingebauten Piepser. Schaltest da ein, deutest ungefähr in die Richtung, die dir deine Inmarsat-Software sagt, da ist der Satellit für dich. Da hast du deine Location an. Das Gerät hat auch einen GPS. Und sagst dir dann, stell mal auf dem Gerät den und den Winkel ein. Klappst du die Stütze aus, seitlich so eine Gradskala dran, keine Ahnung, 30 Grad. Stellst irgendwo hin mit Sicht nach draußen, Himmel. Und deutest ungefähr Richtung Satellit. Und dann fängt das Ding an. Wenn das Signal ganz hoch ist, dann weiß man, okay, besser wird nicht mehr. Dann schaltet da tatsächlich Internet raus.
Und wie schnell ist das dann?
320, 384 Kilobit.
Also vom Megabit-Satellitennetz sind wir schon noch ein bisschen entfernt.
Da sind wir noch ein paar Monate von entfernt.
Ein paar Monate nur.
Inmarsat hat gerade die fünfte Generation in Betrieb genommen. Inmarsat Global Express GX, wo sie nicht mehr in diesem 1,6 Gigahertz-Band unterwegs sind, wie jetzt das Began, sondern im Ka-Band-Bereich, also sehr, sehr hochfrequent. Da kannst du tatsächlich, die Terminals sind ein bisschen weniger portabel als dieses Explorer 300, aber da fällt dann auch mal ein Megabit raus.
Das heißt, Inmarsat ist jetzt eigentlich auch schon weit davon entfernt, nur vier Satelliten zu haben?
Genau, richtig. Die haben vier Satelliten pro Generation und sind aktuell in der fünften Generation. Ich glaube, die Satelliten aus der dritten haben sie gerade ausgeschaltet. Also sie haben immer so ein, zwei, drei Generationen an Satelliten am Laufen, um ihre ganzen Dienste abzubilden. Also Inmarsat hat eine ganze Handvoll an Diensten. Die haben, wie gesagt, dieses Telex-ähnliche System, glaube ich, immer noch, wenn sie das nicht langsam abgeschaltet haben. Also die supporten halt die ganzen alten Systeme relativ lange, weil das in Schiffen verbaut ist. Und solange die Satelliten noch da sind, gibt es keinen Grund, den Dienst einzustellen.
Aber sie bleiben bei vier Satelliten pro Erde?
Aber sie bleiben beim Grundkonzept, vier Satelliten pro Erde. Auch jetzt mit den neuen Satelliten, die eben Spotbeams und jetzt auch Spotbeams mit hoher Bandbreite anbieten können. Und einer der Dienste, die du auch über dieses Beganetz bekommst, ist quasi leitungsgebundene Kommunikation. Also was eben ganz interessant ist für diese Reporter, dass du zugesichert vormals Leitungs jetzt über IP, also dass du 256 Kilobit IP bidirektional zugesichert an Bandbreite kriegst. Das heißt, wenn du eine Reportageleitung hast, wo du ein Video überträgst, dann kannst du sagen, ja, ich werf in den Münzschlitz meines Satelliten-Endgeräts meine 20 Euro pro Minute ein, kann dann aber 256 Kilobit in beide Richtungen übertragen. Das wird verwendet für, wenn du keinen Ü-Wagen mit fetter Satellitenschüssel oder so im Feld hast, sondern nur so ein kleines Briefmarkenbild, ein bisschen Audio übertragen möchtest, dann verwendest du sowas.
Das heißt, wenn man die Pinke am Start hat, kann man jetzt im Prinzip in Amazonas-Dschungelfahren sich da auf eine Anhöhe setzen, wenn man eine findet, und da so Live-Video-Streaming machen.
Mit der Familie skypen.
Wow, ich sehe da ganz neue Entwicklungen in den YouTube-Channels. Ich meine, das ist schon irgendwie echt amazing. Wann ging das los mit GPS? Anfang der 90er Jahre, da war schon dieses, oh Gott, ich habe ein Gerät, das weiß, wo ich bin. Das war schon irgendwie irre. Und dann mit diesen Mobiltelefonen konnte man ja dann auch wirklich in zunehmendem Maße an den vielfältigsten Orten Kontakt aufnehmen und heute natürlich auch breit Internet haben. Die Satellitentelefone wiederum haben dieses, ich kann überall reden, aber ich kann jederzeit in beide Richtungen Fernsehen machen.
Wenn du wirklich diese 256 Kilo bezugesichert haben möchtest, der Dienst, den ich mit meinem Terminal da ganz gerne nutze, das ist der Basisdienst, da zahlst du zwischen 3 und 6 Euro pro Dollar pro Megabyte übertragene Daten. Da kann man jetzt sicherlich nicht eine aktuelle Webseite mit den 20 Megabyte an Bildern und JavaScript und hast sie nicht gesehen runterladen, aber für SSH und ein bisschen E-Mail ist das voll okay.
Ja, oder eben für spezielle Anwendungen und so.
Ich hätte das Terminal mitgebracht zum Angucken und Angriff hin, aber das ist gerade mit einer Freundin auf See-Reise. Die hat das mit auf ihr Segelboot genommen, um Wetterkarten runterzuladen damit.
Stimmt, dafür ist es natürlich auch optimal. Und das hat man dann auch schon nach Datenvolumen sozusagen, nicht mehr nach Zeit.
Ja, wobei Datenvolumen halt auch an der Stelle Zeit ist, weil du belegst für eine gewisse Zeit den Satellitentransponder.
Ja klar, aber das ist halt so, das ist nicht so dieses, ich schalte jetzt die Verbindung ein und dann muss ich zusehen, dass ich in dieser Zeit möglichst viel runtergeladen bekomme, sondern man lässt das halt einfach so vor sich hin dümpeln. Und ja, so auf dem offenen Meer dürfte man ja auch ganz gut Empfang haben. Sind denn diese Zellen auch so gleichmäßig verteilt, dass man quasi dieselbe Zellgröße hat auf dem Meer wie auf der Erde? Oder ist das dann nochmal so optimiert in diesen Antennen, dass man sagt, ja, hier sind wahrscheinlich mehr Leute, die das benutzen?
Nö, das ist so weit over-engineert von der Kapazität her, dass sie sich da keine großen Gedanken darüber machen brauchen.
Das heißt, man hat also auf dem freien Meer eigentlich optimale Versorgung? Das heißt, man kann quasi jetzt in seinem Segelboot über den Atlantik fahren und die ganze Zeit das Live-Stream, wenn man die entsprechende Kohle auf den Tisch werfen möchte. Oha ja. Wo bleiben denn die ganzen versteckten Orte, wo kein Mensch eine Kamera ins Gesicht hält?
Da muss man dann tatsächlich unterirdisch gehen, weil das ist einer der Nachteile von Satellitensystemen. Wenn du halt keine freie Sicht zum Himmel hast, dann ist es essig. Da ist am ehesten noch mit dem Iridium-Pager, der nur ein Fenster braucht, aber ja. Das ist auch der Nachteil von Satellitentelefonen tatsächlich. Wenn du davon abhängst, angerufen werden zu können, dann solltest du eher ein Outdoor-Mensch sein.
Das heißt, die ganzen existierenden Systeme in Masat, aber auch Iridium, die werden kontinuierlich weiterentwickelt und alles geht jetzt in Richtung auf möglichst hohe Bandbreiten Internet mit möglichst viel Garantie auch von diesen Bandbreiten. Genau. Und in Masat ist dabei mit dem Array und dem Spiegel.
Und vor allem dem Ka-A-Band. Also was bei in Masat neu dazu gekommen ist, dass sie sehr hohe Frequenzen dafür verwenden, wo du natürlich mehr Daten unterbringst.
Ka-A-Band ist dann Multi-Gigabit, Multi-Gigahertz?
Ja, zweistellig.
Zwei-stellig. Wenn man jetzt so sagt, okay, alles klar, ich bin einfach definitiv nicht genug erreichbar auf diesem Planeten und ich habe irgendwie LTE und Mobilfunks schon durchgespielt und das ist auch irgendwie nicht mehr cool, weil das haben ja alle in der Schule. Und man möchte jetzt auf so ein Satellitennetzwerk gehen. Was würdest du denn sagen, ist denn so. Mit welcher Argumentation würdest du einem eines dieser Systeme empfehlen und was braucht man an Investitionen, an Gerät, um daran überhaupt teilnehmen zu können?
Das kommt immer darauf an, was man damit tun möchte. Wenn man jetzt mobile Daten übertragen möchte, schränkt es sich insofern ein, dass Lobster rausfällt. Die haben zwar einen Lobster-Telefon, USB-Kabel anschließend, dann ist das ein Datenmodem, aber bei 9K6. Oder noch weniger, 4K8. Also macht keinen richtig tollen Spaß. Dasselbe mit den aktuellen Iridium-Geräten, da fallen 2K4 raus. Man muss also zu einem TRIER-Telefon mit 60kbps oder zu einem InMarsat-Terminal, die sind ein bisschen größer als so ein Telefon, greifen, wo dann halt bis zu 300kbps oder 1bit rausfallen. Das ist also immer die Frage, was man so braucht für Daten und auch was man für Gegebenheiten hat. Also so ein InMarsat-Terminal auf einem Schiff zu betreiben, sollte man eigentlich eine Antenne haben, die sich automatisch ausrichtet, wenn man mit Seegang rechnet. Wohingegen mit einem Theraia-Telefon reicht es aus, wenn man es ungefähr in die Richtung zeigt. Demnach kriegt man halt bei dem Theraia auch nur sehr wenig Daten drüber. Wenn es um Telefonie geht, kann man sich eins der vier Systeme raussuchen, je nachdem, ob man für Global Star jetzt innerhalb der Zone von einem Gateway ist, also ob man das wirklich global braucht. Dafür ist Global Star nicht so das Ding.
Das ist schon lustig, das irgendwie ausgerechnet. Global Star irgendwie nicht so richtig, mehr so der Local Star.
Naja, so Global mit Sternchen oben dran und Fußnote.
Genau, Global Star 1.
Ja, also wenn es unbedingt funktionieren soll und man mit ein bisschen Gesprächsqualität, die sich nach Möthone ganz unten anhört, dann ist man mit Iridium ganz gut bedient. Die fahren auch von den Preisen her ein bisschen unterschiedliche Konzepte. Zoraya ist von der Einstiegshürde relativ niedrig. Da gibt es Prepaid-Karten für 100, 150. Die gibt es bei Iridium auch. Allerdings verfallen die dann wieder relativ schnell. Also lohnen tut sich, wenn man den günstigsten Minuten und Monatspreis haben möchte. Für 500 Minuten zahlt man um die 600 Dollar, glaube ich. Muss man dann aber auch wieder jedes Jahr mit 500 Minuten nachladen, damit das Ding nicht verfällt. Also alles ein bisschen.
600 Dollar zahlt man bei Iridium für 500 Minuten?
Genau.
Und die muss man in einem Jahr wegbraten? Genau.
Also du kannst auch, glaube ich, 250 Minuten für... Also, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber... Es wird umso weniger Minuten. Du nimmst, kriegst du halt umso weniger Monate und umso teurer ist die Minute.
Aber das ist so ein bisschen so die Bahncard 100 der Satellitentelefonie. Also bis zu einem bestimmten Kontingent.
Relativ günstig, glaube ich, ist vom Einstiegspreis auch für die Geräte iSAT Phone. Das ist der Konkurrenzdienst zu Toraya von Inmarsat, wo du auch nur Telefons im Karte rein abgibst. Da sind die Geräte schon für verträgliches Geld und auch die Prepaid-Karten, die es dafür gibt, liegen, glaube ich, ein bisschen unter dem Irium-Preis.
Das heißt, ein erträgliches Geld.
Und unter einem Euro pro Minute, knapp.
Ich meine, was muss man denn für das Gerät zahlen?
Für das Gerät, wenige 100 Euro im Vergleich zu 400 Euro. Also für so ein Irium-Phone, was soll ich für mein, für das letzte, also da kann man schon mal 800 Euro ausgeben. Und so ein IZ-Phone ist, glaube ich, eher im Bereich von 400. Ich weiß es aber jetzt nicht.
Okay, also die ganzen Geräte liegen irgendwo so zwischen einem halben und tausender Euro in Wissen.
Also man muss mit einem Tausender in die Tasche greifen, wenn man dann jahrelang einen Telefon dazu haben möchte. Ganz spannend, auch Triaya bietet jetzt, wenn man nicht unbedingt einen Satelliten-Telefon standalone haben möchte, die haben so Huckepack-Dinger, wo man dann Smartphone reinstecken kann. Hat also einen Connector unten, klickst du dein Telefon rein und kannst dann mit deinem Smartphone über Satellite telefonieren und Daten austauschen. Das ist ganz pfiffig.
Das klingt modern.
Die liegen glaube ich auch bei so 400 oder so.
Jetzt bräuchte ich noch die passende Anwendung dafür. Wie viele Satelliten-Telefone hast du?
1, 2, 3, 4. Ich hab dann irgendwann aufgegeben, von jedem eins haben zu wollen, weil zum einen teuer und zum anderen hat dann Thrya in relativ enger Schlagzahl neue Telefone rausgebracht. Ich glaube die selber haben es schon auf 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12 Modelle plus noch mal vier dieser Satzklaves für unterschiedliche Smartphones. Ich hab von jedem System eins, mindestens. Von iridium 3, 4. Aber so doll großen Unterschied haben die nicht. Also da hat sich verhältnismäßig wenig getan. Das ist halt ein plobiges Telefon mit einer großen Antenne.
Also das heißt, das war zu nahezu jedem Netz, über das wir heute gesprochen haben, auch schon irgendwie eine realen Zugangsmöglichkeit? Und was findest du so am besten?
Das ist wie gesagt sehr schwierig. Also mein Herz hab ich tatsächlich an iridium verloren, weil das einfach ein unglaublich technisch ausgefeiltes Netz für die damalige Zeit war, war auch mein erstes Satfon. Das müssen auch ziemlich lustige Leute sein. Also der CEO von iridium, Matt Dash, hat mal auf einem Podium, hat man das gesehen, wenn man da genau hingesehen hat, Socken getragen mit einem eingestickten Jack Russell Terrier. Und hat dann da, ja, die hat er vom, ich glaube, INMAR-SAT CEO war geschenkt bekommen, weil sie festgestellt haben, dass drei der vier SAT Vorstände von drei der vier Netzen privaten einen Jack Russell Terrier haben.
Also sagt das irgendwas aus über die Psychologie dieser Menschen?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber fand ich, ja. Dem kann man auch auf Twitter add iridiumboss.
Kim, anders täte man das nicht so.
Nee, darf er aber auch, weil er damals, glaube ich, den Deal eingefädelt hat mit dem DoD. Nee, ansonsten bin da relativ leidenschaftslos. Man muss halt gucken, was für Dienste benötigt man und bietet das Netz, was man sich dann da ausguckt, den Dienst an für einen Preis, den man gewillt ist, zu zahlen. Ich gehe aber schon von aus, dass ich da in den nächsten Jahren noch mal preislich einen zweiten Schub nach unten. Der erste Schub nach unten war irgendwie, die Netze sind pleite gegangen, haben irgendwie Alternativfinanzierung oder wie auch immer. Sie haben Schnürsünke aus dem Dreck gezogen und bieten es jetzt für einen Zehntel an. Das war der von 15 Mark die Minute auf einen Dollar runter. Das war Anfang dieses Jahrtausends. Ich gehe von aus, dass das jetzt noch mal ein bisschen sacken wird. Mit der besseren Bandbreite gerade bei Inmarsat wird man wahrscheinlich auf längere Zeiten nicht mehr die 3 bis 6 Euro Dollar pro Megabyte zahlen, sondern ein bisschen zeitgemäßer im Tarif, dass man auch das richtig nutzen kann und nicht nur für Nischen-Anwendungen verwenden kann. Ich muss allerdings sagen, dass auch schon Systeme gescheitert sind. In der Frühzeit gab es Bill Gates, der das Mitte der 90er projektiert hat, TeleDESIC. Da wollten sie ganz crazy nicht nur 66 oder 72 Satelliten draufschießen, sondern gleich ein paar 100 für Breitband-Internet ist beim Projekt geblieben, hat sich nicht gerechnet. In den USA hat auf Basis der GMR2 Technik, diese auch eben für die Pin-Marsat-Mobiltelefone oder GMR1 für Saraya, auf einer ähnlichen Basis wollten sie da ein Netz bauen. Da haben sie, glaube ich, sogar einen Satelliten draufgeschossen. Mir ist jetzt der Name von dem Netz nicht mehr. Jedenfalls hatten die so ein Blackberry-mäßiges Gerät, was terrestrische Telefone, also Mobilfunk und Satelliten konnte. Aber die sind, glaube ich, pleite gegangen, bevor sie wirklich richtig starten können. Haben aber diesen Satellit, der hat jetzt eine Zweitverwendung gefunden. Weil in den USA natürlich das Problem hat, dass du mal ländlichere Regionen hast, wo Mobilfunk nicht so der Ding ist. Auch in Asien gab es ACES, die waren auch relativ früh dabei, auf Basis des GmR1-Standards, einen Satelliten-Metzogosport-Beam-Konzept betrieben. Die haben es auch nicht lange gemacht. Es ist schon immer eine Gratwanderung, diese Investitionen zu tätigen und zu hoffen, dass es Leute brauchen werden. Gerade weil man nicht weiß, wie es sich am Boden entwickelt. In den USA hast du zum Beispiel Google In-Flight Wireless, die Internet im Flieger anbieten, aber nicht von oben, sondern von unten. Wenn so ein Flieger in der Luft ist, dann kannst du natürlich auch zum Satelliten funken. Aber in den USA ist es so, dass es eben dieses System gibt, wo sie am Boden Antennen haben, die nach oben zeigen. Also sozusagen dasselbe Konzept, nur andersrum. Da brucht sich dann der Flieger in Zellen am Boden ein, die auch relativ groß sind, um Daten zu übertragen. Da spart man sich sozusagen den ganzen Wehrtraumaufwand.
Wie funktioniert denn das dann über dem Meer? Nicht. Praktisch.
Ja, das ist für Inlandsflüge.
Welche Netze versorgen denn im Wesentlichen die Flugzeuge, die jetzt auch überm Teich Internet haben?
Da gibt es zwei verschiedene Betrachtungsweisen. Zum einen, wie im Flieger immer, hinten in der Kabine und vorne im Cockpit. Hinten in der Kabine hast du seit Airbus, ne, Connection bei Boeing war das glaube ich das erste, wo du so richtig Internet im Flieger hattest. Das war über Satelliten, wie Fernsehsatelliten, wo du halt über KU-Band Daten übertragen hast. Im Prinzip dasselbe wie DSL über Satellit ohne Rückkanal oder mit Rückkanal. Hast du halt einen ganz normalen Fernsehsatelliten mit seinen Transponder, die 40 MHz rauf und runter blasen. Und ja, hat das an Bord halt einen Antennen-Array, da war das sozusagen an Bord, das Antennen-Grid. Das war wie stationäres Satelliten-Internet mit einer Schüssel. Vorne im Cockpit hast du in der Regel InMarsat. Die waren da auch schon relativ früh mit dran, für den Führerflug spezifische Dienste anzubieten. Klar, du hattest diesen Telex-Dienst, mit dem du den Datagrams, also einzelne Nachrichten übertragen konntest. Das haben sie natürlich alle eingebaut und gerne verwendet, weil das war so von der Schnittstelle her was, was den Flugzeugbauern ganz entgegen kam. Einen ganz berühmten Fall von Inmarsat-Nutzung ist der Flug MH370 gewesen. Das war diese Malaysian-Maschine, die verscheuern ist irgendwo im, war das der Pazifik? Nee, vor Australien irgendwo. Die hat natürlich auch wie viele andere Flieger Inmarsat an Bord gehabt, um bestimmte Daten zurückzumelden. Und da konnten sie dann tatsächlich den Flugfahrt rekonstruieren, nicht anhand der GPS-Daten, die sie geschickt hat, sondern anhand der Laufzeit. Also sie wussten innerhalb welchen, das System muss ja immer wissen, was ist die Laufzeit, um mit vielen Geräten sprechen zu können, muss sie auch immer die genaue Laufzeit kennen, damit die Daten, die du reinschickst, zum richtigen Zeitpunkt ankommen und dass das Gerät nicht zu einer Zeit sendet, wo vielleicht ein anderes Gerät sendet. Also gibt es da eine sehr enge Regelschleife, was die Zeit, zu der so ein Gerät sendet. Und anhand dieser Zeit, die ja im Prinzip der Abstand des Objekts ist, was sendet, und dem Satelliten ist, konnten sie sagen, okay, das muss ungefähr in dieser Kurve hier gewesen sein.
Das ist im Prinzip genauso wie GPS, funktioniert nur andersrum. Das kommt sozusagen nicht unten ausrechnet mit den Signalen, die man vom Satelliten bekommt, sondern in dem Moment haben die Satelliten quasi zurückgerechnet mit dem Signal, was vom Flugzeug kam.
Genau, und konnten eben sagen, also es muss entweder da oben oder da unten sein, weil da oben sich ausschließt vom Flug, du hast da zu einem Satellit den Abstand immer, gibt ja immer zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder, weil das ist bei einer Triangulation, also jedenfalls hatten sie zwei Pfade, einen konnten sie ausschließen und das war dann auch der Pfad oder der Korridor, in dem sie gesucht haben.
Aber leider noch nichts gefunden.
Aber leider noch nichts gefunden haben, ja.
Jetzt gibt es ja schon seit längerem so diesen Traum dieser ganzen Silicon Valley Millionäre, auch nochmal das Internet komplett, die Internetversorgung weltweit nochmal neu aufzustellen und dabei nicht von terrestrischen Gegebenheiten abhängig zu sein. Da ist Google im Rennen, da wird über Facebook gesprochen, das sind allerlei Konzepte am Start, mit Ballons zu arbeiten, mit Luftschiffen zu arbeiten, die so nochmal auf ganz andere Höhen gehen. Denkst du, dass das irgendeine Zukunft hat?
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr ambitioniertes Unterfangen, wenn man sich überlegt, dass Eridium damals, Anfang der 90er, 1,8 damalige Milliarden verbrannt hat für und daran pleite gegangen ist. Hätte nicht jemand anderes die Rechnung gezahlt und sie nur 77 Satelliten drauf geschossen haben. Auf der anderen Seite du aber auch wieder technische Weiterentwicklung hast, also gerade mit höheren Frequenzen, Karaband und so weiter. Es ist damals wie heute ein nicht so unterschätzender Aufwand und braucht dann dementsprechend auch einen langen Atem und gutes Engineering, um damit ein Produkt zu bauen, was so gut nutzbar ist, dass es die Leute gerne verwenden. Und damals wie heute hast du den terrestrischen Ausbau als Wettbewerb. Da bleibt abzuwarten, ob eben die kritische Masse da ist, die das dann auch nutzt. Das Wettbewerb wäre es natürlich, dass man global viel Netz hat. Aber ob die Konzepte mit mehreren hundert Satelliten, die man da teilweise sieht, so wirklich tragfähig sind, oder ob das nicht am Ende des Tages von der Dichte her so viel an neuer Hardware in den Weltraum bringt, dass man dann mit dem Kessler-Effekt unliebsame Bekanntschaft macht, ja, weiß ich nicht. Also das ist so eine der Linden. Ich hab von den Satelliten jetzt aber gar nicht so viel gehört.
Also es waren ja eher so zeppellin-artige Ballonhöhen, wo man jetzt eher so in einem paar Kilometer Bereich ist.
Ich glaube, es gab da so ein Elon Musk-Konzept, was einen sehr an Teledesic erinnert hat.
Und Teledesic war, das hast du vorhin noch kurz erwähnt.
Das von Bill Gates damals vorgeschlagene System mit mehreren hundert Satelliten auf niedrigem Earth-Orbit, die Breitband-Internet machen sollen. Da kam, ich glaube, was Elon Musk gab. Der war nicht der einzige. Es gibt ein oder zwei Konzepte, die sowas wieder vorschlagen. Aber da hast du das Problem, was du im niedrigen Earth-Orbit hast. Je mehr Satelliten du da unterbringst, desto wahrscheinlicher ist es, dass du Kollisionen hast. Und wenn du mal ein, zwei, drei Kollisionen hast, die produzieren ja noch mehr Müll, weil du nicht nur einen Satelliten hast, sondern dann plötzlich tausende kleiner Splitterteile.
Können schwierig werden.
Tja, nibbler. Jetzt haben wir das ganz gut zusammengefegt, das Thema. Oder haben wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges übersehen, abgesehen davon, dass man überall noch ins Detail gehen kann?
Ja, doch eine Sache fällt mir ein. Stimmt.
Ist da überhaupt irgendwas verschlüsselt da oben?
Naja, hat sich stets bemüht. Es ist auf jeden Fall besser, als dass das allererste analoge Telefonieren, wo man mit einem feuchten Windfaden als Antenne und einem kleinen Verstärker im richtigen Frequenzbereich noch mit lauschen konnte. Aber richtig doll sicher ist keins der Systeme. Es sind am Ende Telcos, denen ist hauptsächlich wichtig, dass ihr Businessmodell funktioniert, also dass du nicht vortäuschen kannst, ein Satellitentelefon zu sein, dass du nicht bist. Das haben sie ganz solide hinbekommen. Also sich da Leistungen erschleichen geht nicht. Aber mit Hören ist natürlich möglich. Da gibt es auch den einen oder anderen Kongressvertrag, den wir am besten in den Show notes verlinken, wo eben die einzelnen Systeme auseinandergenommen werden. Fangen wir mal an, GmR1. Das, was Sariah verwendet und das GSM-System im Prinzip im Orbit nachbaut mit Veränderungen, ist genauso geknackt wie GmR2. Es sind zwar zwei komplett unterschiedliche Standards von unterschiedlichen Leuten entwickelt. Sie haben mit der üblichen Geheimhaltung gearbeitet. Also musste die Verschlüsselung reverse-ingeniert werden. Aber das ist geschehen. Da hat man ein Sariah-Telefon der zweiten Generation. Das war ein SO2510. Da sind DSPs drin und eine ARM-CPU. Die DSPs machen die Verschlüsselung und Signalverarbeitung. In einem normalen Mobiltelefon hast du einen spezialisierten Chip drin, das Baseband, was die Telefonie macht. Von denen werden aber auch ARM-Ionen hergestellt. Satellitentelefone sind mehr softwarelastig. Das ist eine CPU. Nur das Allernötigste passiert im DSP, unter anderem die Krypto. Hat jemand, der TI-C55x-DSP-Code verstehen kann, sich mal so ein Firmware-Update angeguckt und in dem Firmware-Update den DSP-Code und einige Zeit später war dann der geheim gehaltene Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus bekannt und geknackt. Bei Verschlüsselung ist Geheimhaltung nichts, was einen schützt, ganz im Gegenteil. Die mehr Augen auf so einen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus draufgucken, umso...
Insbesondere, bevor man ihn zum Standard freigibt.
Richtig, genau. Und irgendwo verbaut, wo man Geräte hat, Satelliten und so weiter. Was auch bei GmR...
Also was heißt das, dass man jetzt bei Toraja im Prinzip jedes Gespräch einfach over the air mithören kann?
Ja, zumindest die eine Richtung. Also bei Satelliten hast du ja mal zwei Richtungen. Du hast da einen Frequenzbereich von 5-6 GHz, das C-Band, der Uplink für Toraja. Da steht auf der arabischen Halbpinsel so eine große Schüssel, die den Toraja-Satelliten anpeilt und über die alle Kommunikationen läuft, vom Boden zum Satelliten und vom Satelliten zum Boden. Und dann hast du natürlich die Telefone. Von den Telefonen kriegst du ja nur eine Richtung, mit die zum Telefon hin. Um also beide Richtungen abhören zu können, musst du beide dieser Beams neu abhören. Es sei denn, der telefoniert mit einem anderen Teilnehmer, dann musst du dir den anderen Kanal, der runtergeht, raussuchen. Aber ja, es geht. Also der technische Aufwand ist nicht mehr so wie vor vielleicht 10 Jahren, dass das nur Geheimdienste und so weiter können, sondern das ist mit wenig Aufwand und öffentlicher Software möglich. Bei Iridium gibt es ein lustiges Dokument, das irgendwann mal auf Wikileaks aufgetaucht ist, aus einer internen Slide Deck. Da stand der schöne Satz drin. Due to the continuously changing Doppler-Shifts and the complex modulation employed, Iridium is un-uncrackable. Das ist nur der most determined adversary an dieser komplexen Modulation und den andauernd sich verändernden Doppler-Shifts drumherum käme. Kann man heute auf einem SDR, also so einem 20-Euro-SDR, was ein DVB-T-Modul ist, empfangen?
Software-Define Radio, wie das Ding, was auf dem letzten Camp ein Teilnehmer ausgegeben wurde.
Also braucht man tatsächlich wirklich nur so ein Billo-SDR für 20 Euro, so ein RTL-SDR nennt sich das, weil der Frequenzbereich, 1,6 GHz, den können die empfangen. Was vielleicht ganz gut ist, eine Iridium-Panel-Antenne, also so eine kleine PUC-Antenne, die auf den Frequenzbereich abgestimmt ist. Und dann kann man da mithören. Relativ niederschwerlich sind die Pager-Nachrichten. Die sind komplett unverschlüsselt. Zack und Schneider waren das, glaube ich, auf dem vorletzten Kongress. Da war ein Vortrag drüber gehalten, wo sie dann auch so einen schönen Graphen hatten, Verteilung der Pager-Nachrichten. Ich weiß nicht, aber ich hatte ein Kuchenstück auf dem Graphen. Weil damals hatte ich noch meinen Monitoring relativ verbost, zwar ohne Hostnames und so weiter, aber da ging halt relativ viel auf meinen Pager. Und das war ein ein- oder zweistelliger Prozentsatz von den gesamten Pager-Nachrichten. Als Wahrheit ein Nischendienst, den nicht mehr so viele Leute genutzt haben.
Abgesehen davon, dass es jetzt, sagen wir mal, mit vertretbarem Aufwand für die bösen Angreifer möglich ist da vielleicht reinzuheuchten, sollte man sich natürlich auch relativ wenig Illusionen machen über die Möglichkeiten der Institutionen. Hier mitzuhören, also nur weil man jetzt eine Kommunikation hat zwischen einem Satellitentelefon und einem anderen Satellitentelefon, ist das noch nicht gleich sicher. Ich schätze mal so Lawful Interception, insbesondere bei Turaia, auch bei so einem Unternehmen, was in Abu Dhabi und Dubai zu Hause ist.
Die sind völlig korrekt mit dem Thema um. Im GmR1-Standard steht sogar drin, dass die Telefone ihre GPS-Koordinaten mit raufschicken müssen. Die werden dann auch für alle anderen Telefone noch mal mit runtergeschickt. Also wenn du einen Anruf machst, dann hast du ja da so eine Handvoll Metadaten. Das eine Metadatum ist, wen rufst du an. Das andere ist, wer ruft an. Und das dritte ist bei so einem Satellitensystem, also von den Interessanten, wo bist du denn gerade? Und die Telefone müssen GPS haben, damit sie sich einbuchen können. Das wird nicht etwa dazu verwendet, um zu gucken, welchen Spot beam, weil das siehst du am Telefon, was du gerade empfängst. Nee, im Standard steht zum einen, muss es die GPS-Koordinaten raufsenden, um festzustellen, innerhalb welcher Landesgrenzen befindet sich denn das Telefon. Wer darf denn da überhaupt LI machen? Das ist so im Standard als Requirement, weil sonst weiß man ja nicht, wer darf überhaupt abhören. Und das andere ist, weswegen sie wieder runtergeschickt wird. Ich halte das für eine haltlose Schutzbehauptung.
Was wird wieder runtergeschickt? Die GPS-Kordinate des Telefons wird an das Telefon selber geschickt?
Nie an die anderen Telefone in den Spot beamen, damit sie wissen, dass da ein anderes Telefon auf der Frequenz sendet. Also Verschwörungstheorie. Sie wollten einfach weniger Leute, die nervig fragen, ob sie einen Zugang bekommen zu den Metadaten, und das einfach selber nochmal runterschicken. Und wer das dann empfangen möchte, der kann es empfangen. Aber rein technisch ist das ein bisschen viel an Informationen, die da nochmal runter...
Also mein Telefon bekommt die GPS-Koordinaten aller anderen Telefone, die sich in der selben Zelle befinden.
Er kann potenziell diese Informationen erhalten, ja. Wenn sie einen Anruf machen. Induziv der Nummer, die angerufen wird. Was eine Information ist, die hat normalerweise nur über diesen C-Band Link runter nach...
Ja, aber was soll denn das da überhaupt zu suchen?
Ja, nischt. Equal Opportunity. Soll jeder die Möglichkeit haben, das abzuhören. Und ja, da gibt es auch Software für die Osmo-Com-Leute. Die sind da immer mal wieder dran an dem GmR-Thema. Da gibt es auch eine Handvoll freier Software, mit der man sich dann auch durch angucken kann, wo die Spotbeams sind, was für Frequenzen verwendet werden und so weiter. Also das ist alles offengelegt. Was ich nicht weiß, ist, ob es zu Globistar irgendwas gibt oder ob sich da bisher keiner die Mühe gemacht hat. Also zu den Trackern, glaube ich, da gibt es da was, aber zu den Telefonen müsste man nachschauen. Aber naja, das hat alles in der Zeit entwickelt worden, wo man sich da noch nicht so die Gedanken macht.
Ja, und jetzt, alles was jetzt entwickelt wird, das wird ohnehin schon mit Überwachungsmaßnahmen im Hinterkopf entwickelt. Von daher kann man sich da jetzt auch nicht so sonderlich sicher fühlen, oder? Also ist das jetzt sozusagen nicht gerade so das Gerät, um von der Welt abzuhauen?
Sagen wir es mal so, wenn du ein Mobiltelefon hast und damit telefonierst, ist von der Funkschnittstelle her gesehen, alles, was du darüber sprichst, gesprochenes Wort in deinem Stadtteil. Also jeder, der in deinem Stadtteil ist, wo dein Telefon unterwegs ist, kann jetzt zuhören. Mit dem Satellitentelefon ist das gesprochenes Wort auf dem Viertel der Erdoberfläche, wo du gerade unterwegs bist und vielleicht mehr.
Ich zeige dir mal, wie man sich nur in dieser einen Zelle befindet.
Na ja, also die Zellen zu empfangen, geht auch weit außerhalb der Zellen. Ah, wenn man eine entsprechende Antenne hat.
Ah, verstehe.
Wenn man mit der kleinen Stab-Antenne-Idee da dran ist, ja, aber...
Das geht schon ein bisschen weiter.
Das ist das gesprochenes Wort für den halben Planeten.
Das heißt, wenn du da in dein Iridium reinquatscht, dann... Gut, da ist es nochmal anders, aber bei Toraia ist es sozusagen der komplette Kontinent.
Drum...
Muss man sich ja keine Sorgen machen.
Würde man also tatsächlich da über so einen Terminal Daten dann VPN benutzen, wenn einem die Daten lieb sind, oder generell? So wie das im Internet halt immer ist.
Ja, genau. Nehmen wir doch mal die Dystopie zum Ende noch mal ganz kurz raus und denken wir nochmal so an Hackerspaß. Was siehst du denn noch so für lustige Anwendungen, die man so mit diesen ganzen Geräten... Also ich fand ja vor allem diese Daten, diese Low-Volume-Daten-Übermittlung.
Da wollte ich auch gerade...
Gerade im Hinblick auf so Sensorik etc.
Das kommt mir auch als erstes in den Kopf. Es gibt, glaube ich, schon Iridium Arduino Shields. Für diesen SPD-Dienst, also für diesen Burstdata-Dienst. Wo ich das schon genutzt gesehen habe, da weiß ich nicht, ob das ein Arduino Shield war, aber wo Leute das gerne benutzen, ist Ballons, so Wetterballon. Das ist im Prinzip so eine Kamera, so eine kleine GoPro oder so. Und du hängst die an einen Wetterballon ran. Tuckers da noch so ein SPD-Modem dran. Und das kann dir dann jederzeit schicken, die GPS-Koordinaten von dem Ding, auch wenn es dann irgendwo landet, wo es keinen Mobilfunk empfangen hat. Also da habe ich das schon im Einsatz gesehen. Und ja, der geneigte hackfreudige Zuhörer, Zuhörerin, kann sich ja die eigenen Gedanken machen, wofür man das so einsetzen muss.
Ja, so Tracking. Man muss ja irgendwie draußen sein. Von daher ist natürlich diese Ballon-Geschichte relativ cool. Drohnen wären vielleicht auch nochmal ganz interessant.
Das ist dann auch noch eine Frage der Ausrichtung. Für Breitbanddaten, so von richtigen Militärdrohnen oder so, da haben sie relativ gute Antennen drin, die das über teils Inmarser, teils ihre eigenen Kanäle zurückschicken. Ich glaube auch, eine ganz gute Benutzung des 256 Kbit Streaming-Dienstes. Für viel Daten musst du genau ausrichten können. Aber für wenig Daten reicht auch eine Stumme Antenne. Da muss man sich überlegen, was man außerhalb der Mobilfunkversorgung möchte.
Ich frage mich gerade, ob man vielleicht so einen 80-Tagen-Um-die-Welt-Drohnen-System bauen kann, was sich immer wieder selber niederlässt und solange über ein Solarpaneel sich Strom reinholt, bis es wieder weiterfliegen kann, dabei die ganze Zeit den Kontakt aufrecht erhält.
Da wäre auf jeden Fall so ein Satellitensystem mit Kurznachrichten für die Steuerung eine Herausforderung. Du kannst dem Ding nicht viel Information schicken, es muss sehr autonom sein, aber es kann sich zurückmelden.
Zumindest so seinen eigenen Status oder auch ab und zu mal die Kamera einschalten, wenn man den richtigen Dienst gebucht hat. Oder auch so Schiffchen, so kleine Motorboote, die man auf die Reise schickt.
Es ist die Frage, was für Dienste in der näheren, mittleren Zukunft kommen. Ich glaube, Reutelsat hat mal ausprobiert mit relativ kleinen Terminals und unglaublich geschickter Modulation. Das waren nicht nur CDMA, sondern sie haben da irgendwas mit einem Array an, das war ein Forschungsprojekt, GPUs hintereinander geschaltet, so Grafikkarten, versucht aus einem unglaublich schwachen Signal mit vielen Reflektionen und so weiter Daten heraus zu extrahieren und haben tatsächlich ein relativ kleines Terminal gebastelt bekommen, was eine größere Datenmenge übertragen kann. Also es gibt da schon so einzelne im Bereich der Forschung zu verortende Projekte, wo mit Satelliten mehr Daten übertragen wurden, als heute so Usus sind unter Verwendung coolerer Technik. Von daher glaube ich, dass da noch einiges geht.
Ja, ich meine, diese Spaßsachen sind ja immer so das eine. Auf der anderen Seite könnte man sich natürlich auch entsprechende Anwendungen in Katastrophen übernehmen.
Kann man tatsächlich inzwischen kaufen. Also das Ding, von dem ich da einen fetten Namen nicht mehr ankennen kann, den Shortnotes verlinken, das verkaufen sie als Satellite Internet of Things.
Nibler, ich glaube wir haben es. Vielen, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen hier über bestehende damalige und kommende Satelliten-Netzwerke. Ich weiß gar nicht, so einen richtig guten Überbegriff kann man hier irgendwie gar nicht so richtig wählen.
Hier hinten auf einem der Telefonen, die auf dem Tisch liegen, steht so ein ITU-Akronym drauf. GMPCS, das heißt glaube ich Global Mobile Personal Communication Systems.
Ja, da kann man ja gleich auf die Bingo-Taste drücken. Okay, das war's. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Bis bald, auf Wiedersehen bei den nächsten CRE.